All right, we're good to go. I think we'll go
ahead and get started right on 4 o'clock. So we'll start the work session.
And the first item to talk about today is a discussion about
the towns at Briley Farms Phase B, an update. And I believe Steven's
got this, right? With Greg?
Hopefully. Or we can just invite Greg up if
you're— OK. Go ahead and tell
us what you got. Let me plug in my— so you can see
what I'm talking about here. Yep.
Good deal. So first I wanted to say thank you.
Last week at the City Council meeting, you approved the first
amendment to the development agreement, and that allowed us to count the 4
that were in lots from— or the 4 lots that were in Plat
2 that we hadn't anticipated when we made the development agreement.
Agree to the sequencing with parks and platform.
So I appreciate that. I used to be on a planning
commission, and one of my pet peeves was when people would
come in and we'd give them recommendations or make suggestions,
and it seemed like they would kind of do some token changes but didn't really
listen to us. And when they came back, it was like,
"Were you not taking notes?" Yeah. So we tried
to take good notes from last time, and. Make some modifications
with Element Homes as architectural partners, and we wanted to come and
kind of run this by you and get your, your feedback.
So last time when we were here, the mayor asked about the possibility
of pushing the townhome back and extending the garage
out 2 feet, and we actually did
it about 3 feet. And so this new design is
24 feet deep on the garage.
And we had the— our architectural partners put in
some different trucks and minivans and sedans because
I remember you asked about different cars and
how they would fit. So this is a Ford F-150 crew
cab and it's parked in the garage.
You can see that they put in garbage cans to scale. Yeah. And then they
have some minivans. There's a Honda Odyssey and a Toyota Sienna and
some different sedans like a Honda Accord and a Honda Civic
and a Toyota Camry and a Tesla Y.
But from our conversation last
time, you said you wanted a garage that was useful and
functional instead of being so tight that you couldn't have both
cars and garbage cans in it. And I remember one
of the questions was a concern about the stairs, if the
stairs extended too far into the garage or if there was a landing that would
reduce the usable area of the garage.
And we double-checked the grades and everything, and all of
the garages will be able to have a one-step maximum. So it's just
one step that's inside the garage and it doesn't affect the
usable space. And the,
the reason why we were doing this, if you'll recall, we had in our
development agreement that there would be 40 townhomes built
that were 3 stories that had a minimum of a 600-square-foot garage.
And we've built 20 of those so far,
and they just haven't been as well received by the market.
And so looking forward at the, the last lots
that we have to build with the larger garage design. We felt
like if we were able to do a 2-story instead of a 3, and with
this updated design that's 24 feet
deep, we wanted to get your input
on that to see what your thoughts were. But we think this could,
you know, still offer a design with a bigger
garage area that's functional, but also would
be helpful to have that interest
from the market. So I'm happy to
answer any questions or hear your
thoughts on it. So would these be in lieu of the 3-car
or the 4-car garages, or would you be doing these 2-car— this
new 2-car garage design also on the other units that were already planned as
2-car garages? So the way the development
agreement was is that there were to be 40 with the larger garage and all
the rest of them would be the standard 2-car design.
And any that we would change would
need to have a plat amendment to the plat, and we want to keep
going forward with the construction of the other ones. So the 20
that have been built are these 4 in Plat 2. These 16
in Plat 3, and then the ones that are left to build
are these 4 fourplexes and 1 fiveplex.
And so what we would propose is we would actually end
up with 41 of the larger garage design instead of 40, but it
would— the 20 that are already done would count towards the
requirement, but we would do it and propose to do an amendment to the development
agreement to allow 21 of these larger garages to
replace the 20, the 3-story ones, with this
minimum 600-square-foot garage.
So if I'm not mistaken, you're asking if this is palatable so
you could come back and ask for another amendment, right? That's how we
would memorialize the agreement, would be a second
amendment to the development agreement. Does it— is there any feedback? Any— does
this seem to meet the requirement that we were looking for?
And I, I didn't mention the garage area with
this extended garage is 496 square feet. So,
so maybe to help the council— What's that?
What was the prior square footage of the garage? The prior
square footage was, um, I believe 421.
421. Yeah, of the 2 stories. Yeah. And this is
496, so. And it's 24 feet
deep. But, but to be clear, I mean, I want to make sure we're understanding
the ask correctly. You're required to build 600 square foot garages now
on those 3 stories, right? Yes, that's correct. And so you're asking to build a
496 square foot garage in lieu of those 600
square foot garages because— and then keep it a 2 story. Because it's
a little easier to market. I mean, is that a fair— is that a fair
assessment? When I say the market, it's not like the marketing,
like the advertising. Like we've, we've taken them to market
and the— You're just having a hard time selling them and you want them to
sell. And so do we. The buyers have been tended
to gravitate towards the 2-story more than the 3-story.
So the changes that would come back are 100 square foot less garage,
and these would remain 3-story or 2-story? So these would be a 2-story.
So it's just the 2 changes from 3-story to 2-story
and the garage from 600 to 500. Yeah. Ford. Well,
and so I'm going to ask a question. I mean, let me say this.
Thank you for listening to at least what our concerns were.
It's obvious that you, that you understood the intent of
at least what my concerns are, and I think probably what the council's are in
general. You're welcome, and thanks for letting us know what the current concerns were.
But with that said,
I get— I guess for me the question would be, would be simply this:
is there a way to incorporate this into more units that
have that smaller footprint or that smaller garage? I don't know if there is or
not. I mean, that's why I'm asking, because if we're,
if we're willing to consider this, and perhaps we should,
I'm not saying that, that I'm a yes or no on it,
but perhaps we should. But if we're going to do it, I'd like to know,
can we incorporate something beneficial like this into the design of some
of the remaining 2-story units? That's what I'm interested in hearing about.
So, um, the,
the intent, um, had been to do the,
uh, the Platt Amendment, and that was
one One other thing that I guess is kind of more of a procedural thing
on these 4 units. We did a lot line adjustment,
which the state law allows and is a little faster and easier for us,
but our feedback from the staff was that it's not as easy
for them, and so they asked if we would have our surveyor do a
plat amendment rather than a lot line adjustment, and we're happy to
do that to make it easier and better for the staff.
But to answer your question, to get up to the,
the 40, it would actually be 41. We were intending
to do the larger garage on the, the 21 units
that are currently shown with the red 3 for the 3 stories,
and that would kind of get above the 40 with
the larger garage. That was the, the intent of the
original development agreement. Can I restate the question?
I think what Councilmember Wright's asking is that these units up
here, what is the size of the garage on those, and would
you increase it in exchange for decreasing these, make those
a little bit more palatable as well? So the other units would
also, you know, in exchange for making these different,
is that right? That really is the intent of my question, is there a way
to perhaps increase the size of those that aren't required to have the larger size
In exchange for reducing those that are required to be 600 feet
to the 496? That's really the question. I don't know if so architecturally
that's something that can happen, right? So from an
architectural standpoint, we wanted to get feedback before we had the structural engineers go
through and redesign the structure. And this, this one's
already been poured, the footing and foundation walls. It's getting backfilled right now,
and this one is getting dug
and poured in the next week or so.
Which ones could you make an adjustment to if you're able to do so?
So I would have to get with Element Homes on their,
their schedule, but it— in addition
to doing the, the re-engineering of the structural engineering, we also
have to do the plat amendment before we could do it. So our
thought had been to do these 5 Last, so there would be time
for the plat amendment to happen. But this one we
were hesitant to because we've already installed the trail. But if we had to tear
out the trail and redo it, we could.
These two, it would really depend on the timing of the
plat amendment. So I, I don't want to dodge the question, but I don't have
enough information to answer. But we, we could get with Element Homes and
see what their schedule is. Get with kind of the planning department and see how
long they think the— and our surveyor— and see how long they think the plat
amendment could take. So I've kind of hogged the time, and I'm going to just
leave this. I'll give you the, my last little bit, and then, and then step
back and, and let the other council members give you some thoughts. I'd be willing
to entertain what you're asking if there is some additional
benefit in creating better off-street parking for these residents
that are over and above those 40 that you're already obligated to do that on.
If all you're going to do is change a 600-square-foot garage for a 500-square-foot
and go from a 3-story to 2-story, I don't care. To me, that's not,
that's not a huge upside. I mean,
it's actually a downside from my perspective in that we're losing,
we're reducing space in those garages. But if you were able to
say, look, we want to do these 496-square-foot garages and
we're willing to incorporate some better garage design to To
incorporate the feedback that we heard council give to ensure that the
people who either purchase these or rent them will have access
to a useful garage. That's that's really what we're talking
about, and they'll be able to store their their their their
garbage cans inside and get two vehicles. I like the vehicles
that you used. I think those are very appropriate.
I think that that many of our residents. Are going to have
2 vehicles in a similar setup. And it makes sense.
It gets them inside. It gives them some protection. And it also keeps
them off the street. So for me, at least, I'd be willing to entertain that
if— I'd be willing to entertain going from the
600 to 496, let you go from 3-story
to 2-story if there's some additional benefit in those units that aren't
required to have the larger That's really what I'm looking
for, is, is there a chance to do that? Okay.
Mayor, can you go back to the one that shows
like the overall— I think
it really comes down to parking,
and I'm grateful that one, you're listening to the market,
and two, that you've made an attempt to change, because certainly
we've had developers come in here 3, 4 times And
every single time it's the same stupid thing. And it's like, you guys didn't
listen to us last time, but you like listened. So I appreciate the
effort to make a change. I guess one of the suggestions that
I would give, and I'm going to kind of look to my fellow council
members to see if this would be enough, what if they added some additional overflow
parking spots in the neighborhood where those homes
have the smaller garages? What if,
even if it came down to taking one lot out to add way more
overflow parking? Because I think that
ultimately would be cheaper than a full redesign of
ones that are already the 2-story ones. So I'm just wondering
if that would make a big enough difference for
my fellow council members.
I've got some questions for you. What's the difference in the width of the garage
from your 3, your 3-story model?
So the, the width is the same. It's 20.08
feet. And the reason for that is the lots are already platted
and we can't make— and all of the utilities are stubbed to
them. That leads to my next question. And so basically we've given up the storage
space behind that was there in the 3-story. We've gone with a
longer garage per se that will enable trucks garbage
cans and even some SUVs to be in there, but we haven't really
gained any ground on the width of the garage.
That's correct. One thing we have gained on though is the original—
when we did the development agreement, the 2 stories
did not have a basement, and now the, the design with the 2
stories has a 520 square foot unfinished basement.
So the 21 Townhomes
that we're proposing to have this 2-story design with the larger garage,
it'd be 520 times 21,
about 11,000 square feet of— I
actually did the calculation, let me look— 11,000 square feet of
unfinished basement storage space that the 3 stories would not have because they're
slab on grade. So my, my concern is width.
I think you should probably remember that from our last conversation.
They need to be able to get out of the car once it's in there,
especially when it's snowing, raining, or whatever. And if
they pull in at the same time, it really is gonna be the finagling that
we tend to see where everybody gets out and somebody backs the car
in to get out. Do you feel like that there's any flexibility
to move that to a 21.5-foot width inside?
Where if it was a paper lot and it was
just kind of a concept, might be possible, but where the
roads are paved and all the utilities are in and all of the— You'd end
up losing the use of those for stuff. The lots, it would be— I'm
less concerned about the parking. I mean, it's a townhouse community. I mean,
there's only so many places you can put parking. I think that you've,
you've shown, at least on this design,
that there's space to be able to park on the driveway.
You can fit inside the garage. I think that's the intent, at least from My
perspective, the width is a bit
of a concern. I don't think we gained any ground on that, and I don't
know that I'm one way or the other not having
the space behind the garage. I think they'll likely use that for a
storage space more than they would use the basement for that. The basement
just ends up being a catch-all, but that's a
decision you guys make. I don't care about that stuff. That's really not us.
That's that's going to be market driven and whether people agree. with that. I think
for me, what we were looking for as far as the parking, I think you've
accomplished that in my perspective. Um,
I, I do like that the floor plan is, uh, a little more
palatable to the people who want to buy it and don't have smaller floors.
So for me, I don't, I don't really have any problems with this.
Great, thank you. I'm, I'm along the lines of what Council Member Wright's
asking, is that if we're giving up space And taking a 3-car and going to
a 2-car, if you can improve the 2 cars in the other areas that
were smaller and you can make those 2 cars larger,
then I would be open to looking at that for sure. So if that's
something you could bring back, I would be open to looking at that. Okay,
let's go back to the other page. So you only mentioned a couple. So what
they've both said, you mentioned that these ones aren't done, but also these ones.
So we're looking at this row and this row that still possibly could
be adjusted. That's what you're asking? Yeah.
And I, again, I don't wanna commit to it. I need to find out.
Well, yeah, I was just out there, I think. Could you state your name for
the record? Oh, sorry. Taylor Keyes with Element
Homes on the sales part of it. I was out there. I believe they've got
this blue. You need to point at it. Here's one of the blue that you're
using. This one's getting backfilled. That one's getting backfilled, and I
think they've dug here. And I guess what I— we'll
have to look at and see what's been submitted, right? But if I'm hearing what
you're saying is go back and say, well, what buildings could be on the table?
So whether that's a function of we just have to say, okay, here's how many
have been pulled, here's what's on the schedule, and then we come back and say,
well, we could do this building or not do this building and kind of see
what that— if that fits what you're looking for. Ultimately, I think the goal here
is to gain more than just the additional 20— Well,
this would be 21 instead of 20. Yeah, and 20,
right. So I think I'm hearing what you're saying is
you would like it to be a greater benefit if we're gonna do this.
Well, it might not be the exact same
as these other units you're talking about here, but at least bigger than what's already
designed as a trade-off. Sure. 'Cause I don't know what the design
is on those. I don't remember. Well, so we had the— so around the perimeter
there, it's the typical 2-story with the garage that was originally approved,
the smaller garage, right? And then we have this 2-story with
the bigger garage. And so the question would just be what units
could we— So it would be easier to do the ones
around the outside just because there's— There's more space. Space towards the boundary.
On these ones, it would be taking up, know, the grass open space or going
into the trail. But so that's something— it sounds like if you can make that
happen, you'll probably get a yes. I, I think we can take that feedback
and get back with the team, and then we can bring it. Zach,
you're going on or something?
Okay. So yeah, I'm gonna— I, I would agree with Brett and Craig.
If we can get a little more value there, come back with that, I think
that'd be fine. Okay, so I'm going to sum up what I've heard,
and if I missed something, let me know. These units on this outside
potentially adding a little bit of garage space.
These ones weren't on the table anyway, so it's just these ones out here.
Maybe some additional parking. These ones
are all built on the south boundary. No, yeah, I was just pointing out the
parking here. So these ones get increased a little bit in exchange
for these ones getting decreased. And then a potential additional parking
similar to this guest parking somewhere. So I was
zooming in on the tabulations when the civil engineer designed it.
The required parking was 378 and the provided
parking was 386, and we had them add parking basically
everywhere that they could. You know, there's a lot of places where it's just 2
parking spots wide because it's in between the So,
and I heard Councilmember Wood say that he was less concerned about that. So is
parking— is more of just a maybe? There's just not a place to put
it. Like, if they've already got the footprints planned, I mean, you're going to
have to start giving up units. I don't think that's a feasible
solution. So the parking's— we're okay with the parking, then it's just getting some added
benefit in these outside units. And I think then, then we'd
consider the— is that good? Anything else?
Councilmember Clark, is that kind of— is that good feedback?
Do you have any questions? Yes, it is. And, and there's a handful of places
that don't have the parking space, but I believe that's where we put the transformers.
So, um, yeah, we'll go back and, and get with Element.
I know this one, the building permits are already submitted and,
and it's going to be dug soon, but these ones around the outside,
we'll get with both the structural engineer and the surveyor and
the planning department and see You know, on both the replatting and
reengineering, and see how quick that that could potentially happen.
And thank you for working with our staff on the replat versus the lot
line adjustment. I mean, if they're asking you to do that, I'm grateful that you're
willing to entertain that. Yeah, and the reason we did the lot line adjustment on
this one just is our surveyor said it's faster. But looking at how
much work it takes to get it updated with the county, I can see why.
The staff prefers the replat, so we're happy to do that.
Okay, thank you for— Do you have any other questions? Okay, I think we're good.
Thank you very much. Appreciate you coming in. Thank you. Getting through that.
All right, so next item, 1B, is a
discussion about Healthy Utah Communities. This is something that the council,
an initiative we've— we talk about every year when we're in St. George, and I
believe in Salt Lake. Um, I know the deadline's coming up,
so Steve is gonna lead this,
tell us what we gotta do, get some direction.
I know the Community Services Board also worked on this, I believe.
And if there are any other questions, go ahead.
Thank you, Mayor. We'll see if it comes up
here. It's not coming up. Okay.
I may have to go hang out in Dave's spot over there. We've got help
coming from the back row. Should be
as easy as plugging in and going. I'll give an intro then.
Yeah, we always go to these conferences in the fall and the spring, and then
we hear about all these communities that are doing great things related
to health and food and mental health.
And active living. And then we're always like,
why aren't we doing this? Let's get going. And so Natalie
Winterton actually did some work on this last year to get us
going. And the city council last year approved a resolution
to authorize the mayor to sign a letter and start the application
process. And then we were lacking in a couple of areas that we couldn't
fulfill back then. But now that we have our community services board in place,
that can act as our health coalition.
We hope that that will work for it.
The Get Healthy Utah organization, the 501 Get Healthy
Utah, put together this
community healthy— Healthy
Utah Community Designation specifically for towns and cities.
And our size requires that we
implement 3, that we have already implemented 3
action items, 3 strategies within 3 different categories.
And the first is active living, and then
there's,
it's related to food services, access to
healthy food, and then— Housing. The last is mental health.
And so at the request of the council,
I started working with our Community Services Board, with Jesse and Charlotte and
the board, and we talked in a couple
of different meetings. We had other priorities pop up, so we've been talking about it
for probably a few meetings, but this last meeting we really dove in and chose
some strategies that we've already implemented,
and then— What are those strategies? Also recommended some 3
additional strategies that we need to propose to
implement over the next 3 years. I can just plug in
over there if we need to. Yeah, it's probably my computer. Okay,
hang tight for a moment.
Okay, we'll try this one, Lacey, if that— and if it's my computer, it won't
pop up, so we will— yeah,
all right, great.
Okay, so passed the resolution last year, requires 9 implemented
strategies and 3 strategies within each of those categories.
And so this just gives you an idea. They have a list of, hey,
here are some recommended strategies within the active living category.
There's a bunch of different things. We can go back to that if, if you
want. Same with access to healthy food and mental
health. And so the strategies that the board
chose to recommend to have shown that we implemented
already or are currently maintaining.
First was to organize a free or low-cost fitness event for your community,
and we do the annual Turkey Trot every year.
It's on Thanksgiving morning, brings out thousands of people.
They love it. That's one of our event staff's favorite
events. And then second was to create an active transportation
plan or update an existing one. So we do have an existing bike and pedestrian
master plan that needs some more updating soon.
But you, council, also approved the off-street trails master
plan just last meeting. And then third,
improve physical activity among the youth by promoting a physical activity resource
program or best practice in schools. The example they gave on
their website is, for example, safe routes to schools. And so we talked about that.
And the schools all create a plan and then
the city helps as much as we can to implement
that. And it's not just having sidewalks
and trails to the school, but it also includes from the school side other
trainings and practices,
activities to help encourage kids to bike and walk to
school. So that's the active living.
There were other options there as well, but those are
the 3 that the board recommended. Second is access to healthy food. So the first
was host a community program to promote healthy eating. And our
library has had a seed exchange that's for vegetables and other seeds that
they've had for quite a while. And that's pretty popular
in there. And then improve access to emergency food by
establishing a food pantry or program or improving an existing one.
I think you're all aware of the food pantry that we have in the library,
the emergency food pantry that's, that's right there in the entryway,
and that's been well utilized by our community. And then establish
a farmers market that accepts SNAP benefits. I've been told that that's what
our farmers market does, that we partner with that group and, and they're there every
Saturday morning during the summer at Quarry Ride Park. And then we've also included
the farmers market in some of our major events recently as
well. And then last is mental health.
First one was we decided to use the other category,
and it's to promote a program to foster encouragement, connection, and hope across the community.
And so the council passed the resolution
to become the first Believer City with the Show Me a Sign organization.
And then we have that event as well, the Motivational Mile.
Second is host a recurring community event that promotes social connection among a vulnerable
demographic. And so one of our vulnerable demographics is our senior citizens,
and the council's been great to support them with funding
and with a location that we expanded fairly recently.
And then they have all of their events that they participate in.
And then third is implement a strategy to promote safe use of guns.
And we do provide free gun locks at our library and
also can promote that on social media and to
our residents. So those are, those are the 9 strategies that were recommended
that we include. And, and then the next section is
to, is to show the data and look at, look at the data
that's out there and be able to determine, okay, what are our greatest needs as
a community so that we can implement 3 new strategies over the next 3 years.
We didn't have time or take the time to go through this in detail with
the Community Services Board. They did recommend some strategies, which I'll show you,
but I wanted to show you some of the research from these, these 3 locations
that are recommended. Public Health Indicator-Based
Information System, which is a— which is on the
Department of Health and Human Services website. The Utah Healthy Places
Index, which is more of a map system, and you go in and it shows
some It breaks up basically by tax areas,
breaks up the city and the whole state. And then Utah
State University Well-Being Survey, which they just barely released the results from that.
So all I did here was include some of the areas that we're
either doing poorly in our community or close
to. Or that maybe I was concerned about.
And so one is the fair— is fair or poor general health. And it's
a percentage of adults aged 18 and older who reported fair or
poor general health. And in our community, that was 16.6%.
That's higher than the Utah average, lower than the US
average. That was a little concerning. 7 or more days of
poor mental health in the past 30 days.
21% of our residents are adults.
That's under the state average and the national average, but still concerning.
And then vegetables consumed 3 or more times per day, just showing do you have
a good healthy mix of food available in our— where there's a red exclamation
point, that means we're lower or worse than the Utah
average.
Another was high blood pressure or high blood cholesterol.
Ours was quite a bit higher than the Utah average.
And hypertension, doctor-diagnosed hypertension as well was
higher. The recommended amount
of aerobic physical activity, and so recommended amount for
adults it looks like is 150 minutes per week of moderate-intensity
or 75 minutes of vigorous intensity.
And it says we're about in line with Utah,
but we're about 9% lower than the Utah
average. Adult obesity and overweight
or obese adults, ours was
slightly higher than Utah in both
of those categories. And then
how well are our female adults looking
ahead and planning for mammograms and Pap tests
and others? And our rates were quite a bit lower than Utah.
And almost done with these, but the suicide rate is lower
than the Utah average, but obviously it's one of those zero fatalities
kind of number that you don't want. to be high at all, if possible.
So that's concerning. And then depression prevalence as well.
Percentage of adults who have been diagnosed with
a depressive disorder, major depression, minor depression.
Ours is lower than Utah average, but still 23%
of our adult population. And then on the wellbeing
survey, For Utah State,
the average rating of personal and community
well-being. So they rate, they rank each of those. And the
last time they did this survey, they're comparing it to the 2020 results.
And so our numbers have gone down on both of those, it looks like.
And well-being domain importance. How important are
the following categories to your overall personal well-being? And they have quite a few categories
there on the left. Mental health is, and safety
and security are the most important to our residents, 96%.
Living standards, family life close behind, physical health,
environmental quality, leisure time, and then it goes down from there.
So just showing those are really important, even if we're doing fairly
well in some of those categories, they're very important. So we should keep
putting efforts towards improving those areas. How connected
do you feel to Eagle Mountain as a community? Looks like most of the
respondents at least felt average
or below connected to the community or
as a community. And then inclusion for individuals with disabilities.
How well does Eagle Mountain include individuals with disabilities in social,
recreational, and cultural activities? 43% probably
didn't have anyone or know anyone that was disabled.
The rest looks like somewhat, quite well, somewhere in between.
There's always more we can do, of course, with that.
So the board,
again, they didn't go through all of that data, but they recommended 3
strategies, that we destigmatize mental illness through a
community campaign or event. And there were several events talked
about. The high school is involved in a
suicide walk, suicide prevention walk.
And then add wayfinding signage for trails that provide both time and distance for
routes, or maybe conduct a messaging campaign to promote
physical activity in the community. And third
is another category, which is to implement adaptive sports and recreation programs.
Or host a recurring community event that promotes social connection among a vulnerable demographic,
which could be our disabled population.
So I know our Jason Hall and our recreation
group have been very interested in implementing some sort of adaptive
program that's that's more robust than what we do
currently. And currently, we just kind of
combine with the rest of the cities in the in Utah
County and Participants
that are disabled, their families have to drive them all over the place to participate.
So one day they'll be in Lehi, and one day they'll be in
Eagle Mountain, and another day they'll be down in Orem or somewhere.
And so it'd be nice if they could stay here and continue to participate.
Steve, there's actually a woman that has been at the farmers market that is promoting
the Special Olympics in Eagle Mountain. She's trying to bring a chapter here.
And so I just want to put that on the radar of the Community Services
Board. I would love to see us find a way to help them as
a vulnerable demographic and see if we can incorporate them into some of our
city events. Yeah, that's a great idea. Yeah, she stopped by our booth at
the, at the farmers market. We all talked to her. That's a great idea.
Um, these were other options that were discussed
or thrown out there as possibilities: establish a community
garden, We do have a couple board members looking into that.
Develop a new walking/biking trail or add to an existing one.
Hey Steve, just, I wanna jump back to that community garden. Is that possible
to do that in multiple locations? Absolutely. I mean, with the size that we
are, it'd be great to have that in a bunch of locations. Could I,
just for context, I know he's wiggling over there about
this, but Brad, we already have some places, right, that you've, that we've identified.
Water run there and they kind of get run down. Do you want to speak
to what's kind of already available and why they're not maybe
used, or at least speak to that for a minute? Yeah,
there's one spot over in the Pioneer subdivision that
has previously been used for a garden scenario, and we
actually had some outside entities come in with,
with some residents in that area. We ran water to the
site. It still exists. After about 3 seasons
of trying to plant it, the garden just never took off and it kind of
failed. And so we haven't seen a successful campaign with that yet.
If we could get to a successful campaign, then I think we start with 1
or 2 and find out what works, and then we can expand on
it from there. Yeah, one of our ideas was to do that
at the senior center, possibly, if we have enough room, where the seniors love The
idea of gardening and helping out with that, maybe they take some ownership of it.
So is that something that they could— it's all kind of ready to go if
the Community Service Board looks into that, or if they— is that something that they
could pursue, or is it
the ground location that's no good? I'm sure that there
would need to be some amendment to it to— I mean, it's been sitting in
a state of— not in a garden state for several years, so There's
probably some prep and whatnot, but yeah, there is a water connection already in that
location. Send a pan or a location so that we can look into that.
It's right next to Pioneer Park on Silver Spur Way.
But yeah, we can, we can give them some info. I was
thinking maybe there's an opportunity to do some teaching how
to start from where it's at, because a lot of people probably are in similar
situations. Perhaps that's a volunteer thing that we can bring some of
our hobby farmers in to teach, and we could use that as the teaching tool
to be able to create our very first one that way. There's a chance,
you know, Jen Corrington that runs the market, she's a big gardener and
in that space. Maybe she could help do some classes. I don't know,
something like that. Yeah, I think the key is to get some community members
that are passionate about it and that are willing to continue and help and help
with the trainings and other things.
Some other options, messaging campaign to promote healthy eating,
offer suicide prevention trainings for individuals or organizations,
and beautify, enhance, or create a section of the community that promotes social
gathering and connection. Those are all kind of options that
they list that we threw out there. And so really,
I guess, really what I'm asking today is,
Do you support the 9 strategies that are shown up there, and then either
these 3, or tell me which 3 you want to pursue over the next 3
years, and then we'll include that in the application and have the mayor sign that
and submit it tonight. We'll get that
in tonight because they gave us an extension to be able to get it in
today. If we want to be— and we don't have to,
obviously, we can wait and take our time if we want.
if you're not ready, but otherwise we'll get it in tonight and then be recognized
at the September ULCT conference.
I'm a yes. Yeah, I think we should move forward.
Yeah, I think the initiatives are great. I like what you've
done to hit each of the 9 things. I'd love for us to— I think
that there's maybe a 2 birds, one stone opportunity. I think there's an opportunity with
some of our undeveloped open space that has
weeds where perhaps we could identify some of those for a garden that
becomes useful to the people who live around it.
Yeah, I mean, I'm supportive of this, and frankly,
I want to thank you, Steve, for your leadership and the Community
Services Board for their willingness to kind of dive in on this. So thank
you. Yeah, I support this.
I would like to see this application. We've been waiting for years to get this
submitted, so like, I want to get it done.
Ditto. Yeah, I remember the very first time I ever went to the ULCT.
I'm like, why aren't we on the list? And so we've been looking at this
for a long time, but, uh, it just needs a signature on the application for
us to get recognized. Just wanted to make sure that we're all on the same
page. And then lastly, is there any other questions from council for
either Steve, or I know 2 of our Community Service Board members? Any input,
questions? Good. Okay, I think that's—
that'll work. Thank you very much. All right,
we'll move on to item 1C. This is a discussion, uh, I know
we came into the office a little while ago and spoke with Roger. Come on
up. And, uh, with concerns about clear lines of sight
for their business.
Turn the— turn that mic on.
Does it— I'll pull it up for you.
If everything's random, turn the mic. There's a button. There's a
button. There you go, it's on now. Okay, we good?
Last time I was able to talk to the city council was in 2020.
I don't know if any of you were here. Melissa was, I know for sure.
Jared was. And, um, that's when we were moving
into this facility and coming in as the— to buy land
for our facility. As you can see, we started building
our facility in 2021,
right at the beginning of 2021. We are a satellite communications
company, and we moved from South Jordan down here.
And one of the reasons was to to be able to get enough land to
be able to do what we needed to do. And so, as you can tell
from the facility, we do satellite communications.
We are a hosting facility where the ground and
the look angles are very important to us.
And so, that's one of the reasons why we're here is to
be able to help you realize that we help other companies to be able
to provide communications from voice,
video, streaming, whatever the case may be, internet data.
We provide that communications for these folks. The thing that's happening
today in the industry is,
rather than going into a lot of detail, there's a satellite
coverage called GEO, which is Greater Earth Orbit, that goes
way out there, and LEO. Many of you have heard of Starlink.
That's LEO. That's lower. And so we are hosting
a lot of lower Earth orbit satellite communication facilities.
And so our contracts that we are developing now,
because we came in, we built, we went through this whole process,
are now coming to fruition, and they're starting to see the value of our facility
and the look angles that we have in our particular area.
And so that kind of gives you an idea as one of the reasons
why we came here. We can go to the next slide, or can
I do that? Uh, no, you'll have to— Okay,
no problem. This is great. Okay, so that kind of talks about what we've done.
When we came in, we had our open house with Melissa, came in with the
Chamber of Commerce. We did our open house in November of 2023.
Um, as I mentioned to you, we were looking for a location.
Now here again, I'm telling you what I remember when we
came into this facility is that the area that we
were looking at was zoned as light industrial,
okay, which for us was very important to us because
of the height restrictions of those particular areas.
It's important for us with a lower look angle facility to
have a 10-degree look angle, and so that of, of 360
degrees. As the facilities were coming into the north,
LKL, I believe it is, the The drywall
company that came into the north of us, the Saltwater Fitness,
Salt Lake Fitness company that came in, they were just— they met perfect.
That was fine. Their buildings were great. Everything was the right height.
But now we're starting to learn a little bit more. If we go to the
next slide. Some of those that we're finding
and that we're learning about and what we're seeing is that some of
the zoning has been changed. And now this could be
true, it could be wrong. I'm not positive or not. But what we're seeing on
the maps is that the facility right to the east of us,
right next to our property to the east between us and Arrow Construction,
which is Willie's place, is now industrial.
Which means if somebody came in there and wanted to build a 5-story
building, that could be detrimental to me.
All right, just because of the look angle of a 50-foot type
building for my particular satellites that they're
looking to the side. We've also learned that QTS,
of course, bought the property to the west, which is zoned agricultural now
but could also go industrial. All right, if they
are too close to us on that side, that could
potentially be a problem as well too. Now, if they built the size of
Meta, a building that, you know, is only 25 to 50
feet or 25 to 35 feet, that would be okay.
But if— and then if they're offset far enough off, that would
be okay too. Does that make sense, everybody? Just that 360
is what we're looking at. And then of course, what really, what really caused our
attention is when all of a sudden we saw construction, you know, equipment happening
to our south. We found out that the city was doing some
there on the water treatment facility, which made us a
little bit nervous. Then they brought in some construction trailers. We did an
analysis where we could look to see over those construction trailers.
We're fine there. But if somebody wanted to build some buildings
there, particularly with the berm that is there, that could
be an issue for us. Just to be able to see over top of that,
because where our property line is on that 10 acres that we
have is critical for us to be able to have that 10-degree look angle.
So that kind of gives you an idea where we're located. Pony Express is the
one that's right there on the right-hand side of the square. That's where our property
is. The new property to the west of us, that green area,
is the agricultural QTS property as well too.
And so our biggest concern right now is to bring the
council as well as the city just the awareness of the fact
that When we came here, we were under— with the understanding that
it was light industrial and that we couldn't get those buildings. That's one of the
main reasons why we came. And so we're here now. All these
are starting to come in. We have numerous contracts now that are
coming in with— which are multimillion-dollar contracts. And if
I have— if I come across a problem where I can't— they can't go 10-degree,
they're going to go somewhere else to do their work. And so that's
all I'm asking for at this particular time. We can go to the next slide.
Is that's really kind of what we're asking for is that we
either look at changing the zoning of those areas around us
or we look at options to be able to just help us out a little
bit just to scoot them back or to allow it so high
or whatever the case may be. But we just needed to bring this to
your attention so that you knew where our
concern was. Any questions?
Uh, one question I have is how far out into these properties
does that angle go? Where— do
you see what I'm saying? Yep. So there's probably like so many feet.
This is Rusty Lake. It's like a property rights issue, right? Like somebody buys
land next to you and what you're asking us is to kind
of restrict their ability Or impede their ability to build on their property.
Right. Which I understand what you're saying. And what I'm kind of wondering is
nothing has been built. Right. As that gets developed and planned out,
could there be a partnership where— Absolutely. We don't put the building on this side,
we put it on the other side. And I'm not even sure as a council
how we can restrict or zone the airspace above
their property. Right. Like to keep that in sight. I have a different question.
Councilmember Hughes, my question is really this.
Recognizing that this sounds like it's a consistent problem for you, sounds like
this is probably not the first time you've run into this, I'm guessing. No.
So it may be one of the reasons why you relocated
to Eagle Mountain in the first place. Exactly. And so trying
to understand that, I guess my question is, I'm putting myself in
your shoes and saying, if I'm this business owner, how do I mitigate these things,
and can I? And so I'm going to ask a really dumb question
because I don't know the answer, and hopefully you'll be able to make me a
little smarter. That's a heavy lift, but some people have succeeded.
Sure. Okay, so it's a challenge I'm going to give you. Is it possible to
raise your satellites up and then to have that angle be down so that if
you do find yourself in close proximity to a 50-foot building that you can
still clear it and have that low To
a degree, yes. The answer to that question is yes, but there's—
you can only go up so high. Do you have any other insight on that,
Rusty? Just on height of the— And the only reason I asked that question is
what you're asking us to do is to restrict adjacent property
owners from being able to petition or ask to
do what they see as their highest and best use on their property, and that's
a real wrestle for us to do that. For me, I'm going to speak just
for myself, um, but I, I want to be cognizant
of the fact that there may be some impacts that, that, that are coming to
you that you're not warm and fuzzy about. But I don't
see this as a lot different than those who come in and say the builder
took away my view and I thought I was going to have this view in
perpetuity. We don't buy the view, we buy the, the ground that we build on.
And so I, I, I'm just I'm trying to kind of wrestle
through this and say, if I'm you and I'm dealing with these impacts and I
can't retard that or restrict it, and I don't know if we
can or can't, my sense is we probably can't and that we probably
shouldn't. And if that's the case, then I'm saying, well, how could we help
mitigate it? Do we as a council need to be willing to say,
look, if you're going to lift those things up 20 feet in the air so
that you can still get that low angle, maybe that's where we could help you
in, in creating a, an exception to perhaps
other restrictions that you're dealing with. So that's an area that perhaps
I could weigh into and say maybe we can find a path forward to help
you with that. Right. And I would just add
to that, I, I agree with Councilmember Wright. Have you had some good
faith discussions with some of those property owners? I'm imagining
they're aware of the issue. They're moving right into a satellite company.
I think we have somebody from— or we had somebody from Meta here earlier,
but have you started those conversations as they're contemplating how to structure
their facilities? Yeah, just for the
record, Rusty Layton with LVISAT. No, we have not had
those conversations, mainly because some of the land obviously
isn't developed yet and the land to the east isn't sold.
It's it's vacant. Excuse me, vacant.
We're looking at options for the the land of the east with some investors and
and potential projects to just purchase that land,
and that kind of eliminates all of it. And I think the core issue
is that when we decided to come out because we looked at multiple
locations up by the airport, out in Payson, things like that.
But Eagle Mountain, when we we discussed with the council back. then, the zoning
was light industrial. And I, and I understand the impeding,
you know, like you don't want your view to change and things like that,
but it was our understanding that this would remain light industrial.
So we didn't have any issues for our long-term contracts, you know.
But then we, we find out recently that, I think it was 2024,
that overlays and other things were changed in those to industrial.
And whether that was because of the business coming in— Right.
You know, we just felt as kind of previous tenants under the light
industrial that I don't know if we want to refer to it
as stepped on a little bit, things like that. But really, it so
we have on this slide thirty-foot and fifty-foot buildings, and I kind of ran some
of the math on this so you could kind of determine from the point of
an antenna. I went off a five-foot bottom of reflector
angle. At a 7-degree, not a 10-degree, but a 7-degree look angle
and how far that setback would have to be around. And a lot
of our antennas, they're not like right on our property line. They're in 40,
50 feet. Some of these will be a little higher on focal point in the
center. So that math changes a little bit. And I also added a buffer for
RF radiation. Not that there's a significant amount,
but it does have to be taken into consideration if
In the distance, you have a 5-story building, and we do it so precisely that
our transmit path goes right to the top of that. You get somebody walking on
top, there's potential for radiation
to that person. It's just something that we have to work with the FCC and
adjoining surrounding companies and buildings when
we're doing this. Those distances are
kind of what we're asking for the areas around us. If it's If
it's rezoned to light industrial, that kind of goes away. But if it can't be,
that we work with the future builders, whether that's QTS
to the west, the city to the south, or whoever
buys the property to our east, that those plans,
they can still build the building they want. We just kind of work
with them to say, here's the distance to these satellites where you would be.
We need an 85-foot setback. Thank you. From the antennas
that are existing, say, on whatever corner of our property.
It's not so much that it prevents people from coming
in. It's more just we work with the future
development if we can't rezone that area back
to light industrial to what it, like, so it's still light industrial across the street
to the north. It's more just our little strip the
2 plots just to the east and then kind of south
there for the city water treatment. If that—
any questions on what I've said? I would say this. I think there's value in
you raising this and helping us becoming aware of it, 'cause I frankly wasn't.
And so I think at least by having an awareness as we entertain some
of those other things, we can certainly have a discussion and see
if there's a willingness on on those who come before us to partner
and to work, to try and work through that. We can't guarantee that, but if
we're aware of it, we can at least raise it. So I think there's value
in you bringing this to our attention. If I could
just— my name is Corey Wofford. I'm the president of our company here.
I just have one comment, and that is, as we sat
and listened to the 2 previous presentations, the first one was about
the size of a garage. And you are all concerned about the
size of the garage. Seems to me that if you can
be concerned about the size of a garage, you could be
concerned about our look angles, is all I'm simply saying.
So I'm just throwing that out. So we, we would appreciate
your appreciation, your, uh— I think the challenge though is that you're asking us to
tell somebody on their land to scoot back to accommodate for
your land that you didn't I think that's where I'm struggling with this.
With the view angles, I'm curious, why 10 acres? Why not 50?
So that you could centralize your view angles and protect your investment
in the future no matter what was built around you. Well, if I needed
an 85-foot setback from my current property line, I'd be in negotiations
with those adjacent property owners to buy 85 feet so that I could secure
my sightline. I mean, that's the kind of stuff I would be doing. I think
that the problem is is they're going to come back to us and say,
uh, they don't own the, the airspace or the land that we have purchased,
and they've spent millions on that just like you have.
Having a council that comes in after the fact is not really to your benefit
because we didn't have the conversations. And if these things aren't dealt with in a
master development agreement, what really can we do?
Not change the light industrial. That's what we came in on.
It's Light industrial. It's RTI, I believe.
Isn't that Sweetwater Overlay Zone though? That's what I think. The one there is.
It's the RTI there, right? Yes, it's RTI.
I have some things to share with you as well to kind
of add some more information. Let's see what you have to say.
Let me add a few thoughts
here. We'll skip to some of this.
So looking across the street to
the west, this is the site plan for the QTS
expansion. And let me see
if I can zoom in here. Yeah. Why is it doing that? I'm gonna
try to zoom in there.
So you can see, The site's
just across the— it's right here. And the
distance from the property line to the edge of this retention
basin is 320 feet.
You've got a whole right-of-way. I don't think they've got
a lot of concerns. That's what's going to be built is the retention basin.
Do you know what the height of the building is, Brandon? Checking on
that, I think they're under 50. I'm not 100%.
Actually, we were in the process of looking that up.
If I have that before we're done, I'll let you know.
But we've got we've
got a facility that's that's kind
of built in some buffers with its adjacent neighbors there on
Brandon, can I ask where Magnolia is at on
that drawing? It's right here. It's Virtual
Drive. That's Virtual Drive is what Magnolia is? Yes, Magnolia.
Okay. You've had, as far as development to
the south of the property, you've had the new tertiary
treatment building that was built over here. It's possible
that our city could build additional buildings to the
south. I was— Brad was just checking
the elevation. The grades to the south on our
property actually are a little bit higher.
In fact, Brad, I think you said that the grade where
We're on our property may be close to the height of the satellite dishes now,
so that that is something to consider. That that
land to the south, and here's a zoning map.
It's it's in the LMD.
Most of this, so to the west of the is the ag zone
with the RTI, except for this piece right here where
we have our. where we
have our ponds there. The rest of it over here is
in the light manufacturing distribution
zone or the business park
light industry. That's what our park— that's what our zoning map's telling
us along. And you can see the Sweetwater overlay.
Okay. Ag zone,
the height there is pretty low. Well, the issue is the
RTI. RTI will let you go up to 50 feet. However,
it does have the ability to go above that provided the
right approvals are given. Business, park, light industrial,
there is an issue with our zoning map in that the truth
is that business park light industrial zone is actually a land
use designation and not a zone. But essentially what I'm getting
at is the light industry zoning that you thought
that was there, it's essentially still there.
I don't know that the zone— what's changed is the RTI zone
overlay, which allows you to go up to 50 feet and virtually everything
in this whole So the entire image that I'm showing you is now in the
RTI overlay zone with the exception of our
ponds right here, the parcel with our ponds.
Are those ponds right at the bottom there? Yeah, circled in
blue. Go to the other ones. Are those ponds going away?
No. They retain? Yep,
they'll be retained.
It's possible that our land here and
the public works property, it very well could be rezoned
to the public facilities zone, which would be a 35-foot
height. But again,
you've got that grade difference between your property and
the city's. Sweetwater overlay zone
is something else we haven't talked a ton about, but it doesn't actually
have its own height requirement. It has—
it basically relies on the bases, the zoning,
or the height of the base zone, which again
is basically a light industrial zone as you know it.
Mm-hmm. And here's the current
future land use map designations. Most of its business,
Park Light Industries.
So I think that
your neighbors to the west, again, have been taking
a look at trying to mitigate
impacts by putting retention basins and so forth and creating
a separation from you. So I don't think you've got a lot of concern with
QTS.
I'm—it's possible. I guess the city could build a taller
building, but I mean, I don't think it's super common in a
public works facility to have really tall buildings.
The other thing too—you and I talked about the idea that these parcels
off to the east are land that's undeveloped,
and it is possible to to to consider acquiring
that. to provide yourself a buffer.
And then across the street, you've seen some
of the development that's occurring. You've got the LKL facility
and then the Salt— I'm forgetting the name of that building.
The Salt— Salt City Fitness. Salt City
Fitness or whatever. And so I think you're kind of getting a taste
of the heights that are— that you should expect
across the street. So I'm trying to help you get an idea
of what's being proposed,
what's possible. And I think there are some things that
I'd be concerned about and some maybe a little bit, but I think
a lot of things that probably should give you a little bit of hope.
It's knowing that QTS is taking care to
set their development back quite a ways from your property line,
knowing that— That's huge. I didn't know that before we came in. So this
was— that's good information to know. I think, like you said,
if that's true with what they're putting in there and stuff, that will give us
enough room to be able to make that happen.
Is there somebody— yeah, sorry.
So is there somebody with QTS that we could get information
and swap so that we can actually discuss that in a little more detail,
and I could sit down and do the math with it and just make sure
that— I've got a guy named Mitchell Bisbara that you can talk
with. Okay, I'll get you his contact information. Thank you, because we're more than willing
to talk with anybody and everybody that we need to, to be able to help
us work together on this. That's what it's about, being good neighbors, right?
Absolutely, absolutely. Our biggest thing is that particularly
We understood that, you know, to the west of us, we were a little concerned.
We figured we could work with all of you all with the south.
We figured we can— we've got— hopefully we have some camaraderie
here that you loved us enough because you let us come in and you knew
what we were doing. We want to see you succeed. Exactly. And so we appreciate
that. On the east side of it, I'm also talking with, you know, the development
group, you know, the RE/MAX group, And I think his name
is Richard Farnsworth, who's selling that property to the east.
I've already been in conversation with him and looking at talking
with him to see that, because I do have some potential folks
that might want to pick that up earlier than later. So we can check
on that to see what they're doing, and he's keeping me abreast as to who's
interested in that property as well too. So we are working on that
as well. So I think it's good for Just for us to be aware of
the issue, just as plans come forward, that that's in our heads and we're
just aware of it. So that's good. That was my main purpose, was to let
you folks know where we're at, what we're doing. We appreciate you very much
for this opportunity to be able to bring this to your attention. We thank
Brandon for coming out and seeing the facility and looking over things
and all that to be able to help us out with that.
So just one brief question. So are you able to Raise
the elevation of your satellites? To some— well,
with some of them, yes. But, but to, you know,
so much, I mean, I'm thinking maybe 10
to 15 feet. I mean, but there's some
of them that are smaller, all right, that have a 17
by 17 pad, all right. But then to be
able to build that up a little bit, that could be tough. It could be
tough. Could it be done? Possibly. I'd much rather work with
the neighbors and work with folks to be able to help it so we could
just stay at the elevation we're at. It'd be much less
cost.
We turned off your mic.
Okay. No, there is a question over here, Brad.
Just for context on our site, it looks like there's,
from the top of our pond to the road that the
satellite company's on, there's like a 10 to 15-foot
offset in grade. Right. So I don't think we have any intent
with our buildings to build anything more than a 2-story.
Right. But the 250-foot
Just for context, from the property line, that basically takes
in almost our whole buildable footprint for our treatment plant facility upgrade,
and we don't have a big option to move that. So it's
good for us to be aware with this, and we'll have to work with you
through this process. I just want that to be clear and on the record.
Are they looking at right to the south right there,
or— we kind of told that it might be a little bit more north and
So the phase that we're on will be north and east,
but as time goes on, there will be more that will be built, and that's
where that treatment plant is gonna expand, just so that it's on your record
and on your radar. Okay. I just
wanna speak to that 250-foot number. So that's— I
don't wanna necessarily use the term arbitrary, but there is a buffer in there that
I kinda threw in just Again, it's at like a 7-degree,
kind of a lower kind of 5-foot offset.
So that's something that we can discuss a little more. And our antenna systems,
there's 2 of them that are already placed now, and the pads for 2 more
are there so that you'll, if you were to be at that construction trailer,
you would kind of see where they're at. So they sit in about 40 feet
already on our property. So that takes it down to 210. And then
we figure in some more like where any potential building will go.
I anticipate that number being smaller than 250. That's just kind of
a safe zone that I put in at first just to kind of give an
idea of where we're at. But Brad, I appreciate you
letting us know that because we do need to visit on that if there's any
way that— I mean, those— that berm that's there, I kind
of thought that berm was there just because of the water treatment plant You know,
the ponds were there. I thought that that possibly could come down
if there's a build that was going to happen there. And I'm not
saying that it can't come down. There's probably potential that some of it can come
down, but I just don't want to set the expectation that everything's going to
be at that ground grade because we already have a lot of
infrastructure and a lot of it's going to run off elevations.
And so we'll just have to probably coordinate with you offline.
Okay, sounds great. Appreciate it. I did just
want to point out that these buildings to the north of you, they're all— this
one looks like it's a little less than 24 feet.
This one is typically—
looks like it's on the order of 24
feet on the side. Maybe at the highest
point, you're Yeah, I'm not seeing much more than 24 feet.
So I don't expect typical development
a lot taller than that over on those parcels, but it does give you kind
of an idea of what to expect for future development.
Thanks, Brandon. Appreciate that. All right, thank you. Thank you very much.
I don't think there's any other questions, and glad to have it on our radar.
Okay, appreciate you. Thanks, guys. Thanks very much.
All right. We've been working
on this for quite a long time. It's item 1D.
I know Brad started this months ago,
and Ben's trying to get a little broader picture,
but just to show both the residents
and the council the workload that we deal with on a daily
basis, I think, here in City Hall, this is a a little
bit of a higher-level view of some of the bigger projects.
And we'll, uh, Mayor, we talked about keeping people's mental health good.
Are you sure this is a good idea? I don't know.
It's, it's never good when you're looking at me. I don't, I don't know.
I have that effect on people. But Mayor and Council, thank you so much
for the opportunity to visit with you a little bit.
And, uh, it's important to note, especially for the public,
that There's really 3 main things
that the city gets involved in. It gets involved in day-to-day
operations, and that's not included on
this list. So there's a lot of things that we do on a day-to-day basis
to make sure that people have high-quality water and that that water is processed properly
afterwards and that they have parks. And, and so there's work that we do day
in and day out to make the high quality of life that we have for
the residents. Possible here in Eagle Mountain City. Then of course
there's emergency response, and that happens all the time as well.
I know you get texts from me in the middle of the night, hey,
this lift station went down, or this water tank is having
an issue, or this well's having a problem, or whatnot. So that's not part
of this either. Really what we're talking about today is our projects
that we have, and I want to give maybe a little bit of definition to
that. We have what we would call capital projects, and that's something that
would be capitalized at the end, that there would be a technical asset at the
end, like a water tank. You've got a tank, here is a project.
It starts off with trying to figure out the funding, trying to
come up with the initial design, do land
acquisitions, going out to bid. We have all sorts of processes that we are
required to follow, set by code, set by you, the council. council so that we
can make sure that we're doing things properly and we're doing it in accordance
with not only the laws and ordinances of the City of Eagle Mountain but with
the state of Utah and federally as well. We also have projects
that are not necessarily capital projects but just projects that we would
kick off and take on that would still maybe have an asset
at the end. For example, we're looking at the
observatory, and so That's one
where we're getting donations coming in, and there's a lot of work in the background
where we're getting grants and donations and whatnot come together.
There's a lot of work up front, but it's not something that you're funding as
a true full-on capital project. There's something
that I would call an initiative. So maybe we have a really good idea
come forward. Maybe we want to look into a justice court. Maybe we want
to look into solid waste and large— getting
rid of solid waste, large items and whatnot, and new programs that
we can offer to enhance the quality of life of our residents. Those often
take a lot of steps as well with many departments involved.
And so it's sort of like a project, but it's really an initiative. There's not
like an asset at the end. It's really a new program or a new offering
that might come forward. And then sometimes we just have some simply hard tasks
that are really time-intensive Maybe we're trying to do a certain land acquisition to support
the school district or something of that nature. So consequently,
I've been pulling information from various lists that we have,
trying to give you a consolidated list of
all the different projects. And even the one I sent out had
some spelling errors, which means that the form— formats are not— that
have been fixed since I've sent it out. aren't sorting exactly perfectly.
But really, we're trying to consolidate a project, a capital project list,
projects, initiatives, and even right down to the listening tour that you
have going on where you're going to various neighborhoods and residents are asking
for things. Some of those translate into a quick,
quick answer, and some of those are a major project that we're taking on or
potentially taking on. And every project out
there is has the potential to make life better for our residents.
And so we want to truly look at all of
those projects and, and, and we want to give them the due diligence
needed. But the— and sometimes the enemy of, of great
is good, because we maybe have, um, something that we really,
really want to accomplish, and then we might get diverted with other things. And so
as staff, we want to make sure that we're fully aligned with the will of
the people, which you are their elected representatives. And so we
want to make sure that we're working at your bequest and doing the things that
you would have us do. So how does that— I'm just going
to go really quickly through these first few slides and get right into the projects.
But how does the city go about doing that? Well, you know, we have
in the past, and this is more maybe for the sake of the public,
we in the past have tried to determine what our values are as
a community. And what we want to provide. And that's, you know, a healthy and
safe community. We want to have accountability and transparency. We want
to provide great services for our residents, innovation, make sure we're growing in
the right way. We want to be efficient with the dollars that we're entrusted
with, and we want sustainability. And we want to make sure our
programs can, can be sustainable and not just be one-time,
one-off. And so when we look at our values, we try to tie
that back to our strategic goals and what the council would have us work on.
And we know that you guys are going to— you're all going through a process
right now to update these. Um, where we have a new council, we're going to
be making tweaks to this. And so we want to rep— uh,
respect the fact that things do change over time, and so we need to be,
uh, flexible. But our current stated goals are
really to have a diversified economic growth. Anything that we do,
we need to be able to have the golden goose that be able to keep—
have it keep going forward. So we don't create an undue burden on our residents.
We want to have robust infrastructure that, that really can stand the test of time,
unique reputational, um, evolution.
We want to, we want to have something different when you come around Unity Pass
or coming right into Eagle Mountain itself right at the beginning, uh, from Saratoga.
You want to feel the difference, what it's like to come into Eagle Mountain and
feel what Eagle Mountain's all about. We want to be proactive and generational
in our planning because we have kids that we want to be able to retain
and keep here in the future. And so we look at schools and universities and
all the different things, job creation, to keep our kids and our grandkids near us
at home. We want to have interactive environmental stewardship.
We don't want to damage our home and what
we call our hometown. And we want to have dynamic services
and enhancements. We want to make the quality of life better for the residents that
we serve. So we start with our mission statement, and this is Eagle Mountain's mission
statement. That may be tweaked in the near future of upcoming retreats.
And then from that, we've really tried to prioritize the
task that you would have us do. And that's really done on a basis
of, first and foremost, there's nothing
more important than having a strong foundation of public safety.
That is the foundation. That is the basis. And so
that's when we look at our public safety as being the most important.
Important aspect of our community. If we can't go home and have a safe community,
have police, fire, and EMS response, then really we
have nothing that really we can offer. But on that foundation,
we build— we should have a balanced approach to providing
essential services. That's all the infrastructure that we would provide.
Economic prosperity so that people have the ability to learn and grow and have jobs
here in our community. And ultimately, we have a great quality of life that we
provide our residents. And so when we think about all the different tasks that we
could take on or all the projects, the more that they can cross over and
achieve more than one thing, the better off we are. So if we take on
a project that not only enhances our quality of life but attracts new businesses
in as well, and our essential services that maybe this
business brings, the infrastructure can support our overall community.
Community as well, and that creates stability in property taxes that
can be provided for our public safety, that's a win across the board. And so
we look at this and we want to make sure that we're doing it and
doing it in the right way, because sometimes communities get out of balance
fairly easily. I always have used this slide since
the very beginning of being a city manager. I am absolutely confident and
I have nothing but faith and trust in the, in the city staff That we
can do anything that you want. We have talented people,
great people on board that can accomplish whatever you would have us accomplish.
But we can't do everything. We can do anything, but not everything. As soon as
we try, that's when we fail, because we're spread too thin. We are
your engine. You are the drivers. You tell us where to go. We will get
you there. That's the whole ultimate thing. We talked in one of our
last retreats about financial best practices. need to use budgeting as a
tool to establish our priorities into tangible dollars so that projects
really do move forward in a manner that you, the elected leaders,
would establish. Our, our enterprise funds should be,
um, and what are enterprise funds for the sake of the residents? An enterprise
fund is a fund that we consider to be like a business.
So our water fund supports water, and our water rates should be,
uh, set and established such that they cover the costs of running that enterprise.
Sewer for sewer and storm drainage for storm
drainage, all those different enterprise funds are treated as businesses. Our general
fund is much larger, and, and that's where we take some of our other things
like public safety out of. I have used this quite
a bit, that we can't spend our income, we can only spend our
income. So real dollars is what we can actually
plan for. In Eagle Mountain, I have learned that there's another term
called when-come, meaning that if-come is if it translates.
But let's face it, Eagle Mountain is growing so quickly and we have things
being built on the fly. We know that they're going to come, and so it
is a matter of when some of those financial benefits will hit our residents.
And I truly believe that it's going to transform our We're on a tipping point
of where we're going as a community, and so long as we create a
financially stable environment, I believe very
firmly that Eagle Mountain is going to continue to bloom and prosper with great
jobs, great opportunities, and quality of life like we've never had
before. We don't want to spend one-time dollars for recurring purposes.
We want to create stable, sustainable revenue
streams streams. So, and we want to tie those most stable revenue
streams to our most essential services like public safety. We want to maintain
what we have rather than replace. We got to take
care of what we own. It's kind of like changing the oil in your car.
You change the oil in your car so you don't have to replace that car,
right? So we take care of what we have. We should only dip into
reserves for emergency purposes. It's better for us to own versus rent.
So we have to think about that when it comes to, like, city facilities.
And that the city is like building a house. When we build a
city, we start with the foundation and we work our way up. And many years
I've spent in another city where all
we wanted to talk about was what color the house was going to be,
or what kind of curtains we were going to put up, or how large the
kitchen was. But there was nothing more important than starting with the foundation and making
sure it was stable and strong. Thank you. And it had good compaction, and then
we start building the walls and the roof to make sure it's not getting wet,
and we do things in the right order, and everything else will take care of
itself. When it comes to revenue, there's really three main revenues for a city: it's
our property taxes, our sales taxes, and the fees that we charge.
And so we have to have balanced and stable revenue
streams. And if we rely on on things that are changing
from time to time, like sales tax, then we follow the winds of
the market and not necessarily the stability that comes from
having diversification of our revenues.
With that said, I use the analogy of a house.
What is the foundation of our house? It really is public safety.
From that, we have to have our infrastructure, which is our public works, and that
builds our essential services. From there, we can have our economic prosperity. And when it's
all said and done, that enhances the quality of life with the color of the
curtains or the color of the house or whatnot. And so all
of these tasks, we really need to start looking at them, all these potential
projects that we're taking on, we need to look at them through the prism of
what is the most important. And oftentimes we
have to deal with the urgent. Sometimes the urgent is, hey, there's a water
leak, a water main blew, and we got to go take care of it.
But the important is maybe we need to be checking every single
one of our sewer manholes on a regular basis, on a routine,
to make sure that we're not— and we're cleaning out our sewer mains so we
don't have a backup. You know what I mean? That's regular maintaining maintenance.
That's important. The urgent is when it gets blocked.
And of course, then we also have things that are not important nor urgent,
and those are things that can waste or be time wasters. Okay. And so when
we start looking at that and we want to try to become more effective as
an organization, we also have to recognize that we have certain bandwidth
and we also have certain growth that we need to do. And so I'm trying
to really work hard to build the future of our city.
We're about a third the size of staff as comparable
cities of our size. And so I recognize that staff that I
do have today are the leaders of the future as we continue to build
more and bring more frontline employees on. And so we're
doing things like a leadership training program
right now where we have more than 55 members of our staff, either current
or future leaders who want to be future leaders, learning about management
principles and leadership principles and how they can better grow and
lead their organizations going forward. We can't all do it.
We've the bottleneck if we don't rely and trust on others and let them
grow in their roles. So we're looking at organizational alignment and policy
maturity so we can go from a crawl to a walk to a fly.
And I— and of course I had to put the fly in there because if
there's anything I like, it's aviation. So what's—
what are the major projects? I sent a spreadsheet out to the council,
and that spreadsheet is actively being worked on by our
functional area directors and their department heads right now.
And so it is changing on the fly. But I just wanted to review
for you and for the public some of those major things that we have going
on. And I want to talk about how best
and what your direction would be on how we could prioritize those.
Because some things, it's going to be challenging to prioritize because they're already
active. We're already moving forward. So those have been approved
in the past. Some have the opportunity for us to be evaluated on whether we
should take them on or not. So I just broke
down some of the top ones, not all of them, but some of the top,
uh, projects that our current, um, city staff is wor— working
on to make enhancements right now to enhance
the quality of life of our residents. And these are not ranked, these are just
thrown on the board, and we are looking to our elected leaders and
the public in general to help us rank some of these. But Um,
I've broken them down into logical areas. Public Works,
Transportation— that's probably the hottest item on anyone's radar,
is that we want to get in and out of our community more, uh,
quickly, but we want to do so in a manner that's safe for our residents.
And so we're currently doing a pedestrian safety study
and looking at speed tables, pedestrian safety enhancements,
and the council has authorized and wants us to move forward
to ensure that we're putting in— it's not necessarily speed tables, but we're putting in
all of those improvements that are going to enhance the safety of each
elementary school, each middle school, high school in our community.
Silver Lake, Woodhaven, free right turn lanes. That's going to get people out of
those neighborhoods more quickly. Silver Lake community traffic
improvements. We're looking at the connection to the high school, and if we're going to
make that connection, what improvements do we need to make to intersections going north to
make that so that those— so that
added traffic doesn't negatively impact the elementary schools in
that area. So we're looking at removing roundabouts and putting new traffic signals in,
having better crosswalks and better pedestrian crossings.
Branches Parkway median removal. David's working on removing
those medians. There's really 2 projects that are going on, the High Tea
Campus Drive in Ranches That's going to make it flow better as you're going north
and you're over by the turnoff to the chamber or the
city offices to the north. And also to the
medians and making that wider so that we can have 6
lanes and then a center turn lane on that
Ranches connection between our 2 major arteries.
Trailhead, that's the intersection right outside here, and being able
to put a light in at Trailhead and Pony
Express. We're working on expanding and widening
Pony Express going south of Eagle Mountain Boulevard. Right now
it's 2-lane. That's going to be 4-lane. This is something that's going to be funded
directly by QTS. And so we
really appreciate the data centers and their contributions to trying
to enhance the quality and flow of traffic
in that area. But that's
really, um, widening it, um, to 5 lanes all the way south to,
uh, Pole Canyon Road intersection, and then putting in, uh, the new intersection
improvements there at Pole Canyon Road. And then of course we're updating our Transportation
Master Plan, Impact Fee Facility Plan, and IFA for anything transportation.
That's actually on the agenda tonight as far as the Transportation Master Plan
is concerned. These are not all the transportation projects.
These are just of the ones that we wanted to highlight. We would like your
input on how to prioritize them, um,
as we move forward— these and the ones that haven't been listed.
Um, Public Works and Water. We know that water is the next most
essential asset in our community, and making sure that we have water,
uh, resources for our community to continue to, to blossom, to grow,
so our kids and grandkids can live near us. Um, And not
just in my basement like I have mine. So Central Utah
Water line and a secondary water line is is being
planned right now in the new booster station, City Center.
We have a new water tank going in on the side of the mountain over
here. The council just took a tour of that on the hillside there.
We have repairs to Well Two going on,
enhancements to Well Five. Well Seven is under design
right now. That's by Unity Pass, and that's where
a new well house will be built. Well 8 is about to come online,
and Well 9 is about to be drilled. So we have new water resources that
we are putting in, and each one of these wells takes several years to develop
and several million dollars per well to have them come online.
We have the new Bell Street booster station that's over by the, the new middle
school, the Butterfield PRV valve Creating pressure zones.
White Hills Booster Station. Oops, I got
White Hills spelled 2 different ways. But White Hills Well upgrade
that needs to take place. Culinary Water Master Plan,
IFFP and IFA. And allocation-based tiered water rates
analysis. That's something the council's had us work on where
we are looking at how much water had been dedicated, not based
on the property size, and so we're
creating undue restrictions based on arbitrary numbers. But we are looking at
how much water is dedicated to each lot, and that we're charging the appropriate
amount based on what someone has brought in for the benefit
of their home. And so, and creating more realistic, so if people
are overusing water, they're charged appropriately, and if people are within their water that
they've delegated, Great. And so we're doing all sorts of things to try to enhance
our overall water usage. When it comes to
things like wastewater, we're working right now on the wastewater treatment plant.
This is a 6 million gallons per day enhancement
to our sewer treatment system. This is— there's
some major hurdles that we're working to overcome there. Of course, we're going through the
bonding process right now. Getting rated for this major project.
But we also are working with the state to get our permit
in order to put this project forward. We're trying to get a reuse permit
so we can reuse that water and, and, and make precious
use of every drip every time over and over again. And effluent
planning— we want to make sure that as we're taking water out of that sewer
treatment plant that we're doing it in an appropriate way and we're getting proper
return flows but not doing it in a manner that could create environmental
risk or hazards. Part of that is we're enhancing our
current treatment plant with a tertiary treatment phase 2. We also recognize
that as we put new sewer infrastructure in, we have to have newer sewer
trunk line— sewer trunk lines to bring that sewer influent into the sewer treatment
plant. So we have an east sewer trunk line underway.
Like I mentioned, the effluent disposal upgrades Um,
wastewater master plan, IFA, IFFP.
Um, we're cleaning up our boundary with TSSD for the north area of our
community right now. And then we have things like,
uh, that pop up, like the Scenic Mountain neighborhood that wants us to
look at their lift station and should we bring that in as a city asset
or not. And so we're trying to do evaluations on that, and we're trying to
get data from them. And also other projects to support
specific neighborhoods like the Lone Tree, Forest Main, um, and etc. There's,
there's many more projects that aren't listed. These are just some of the wastewater
things that we're doing today. We also recognize that we
have parks and we want to make those parks, um, accessible and usable and
raise the quality of life for our residents. And so some
of the things that the, the community may not be aware of that's going on—
a lot of people have asked, what are those poles going up at Cory Wright
Park when they're in the middle of nowhere? And they're— what's going on those poles?
Those are actually festival field lighting, um, to enhance and,
and light that area so we can do more events at night. We're putting
a new parking lot out at Quarry Ride Park. Um, we're probably going to
be putting on those light poles, um, added, uh, Wi-Fi so we
can have better, um, uh, utilization out of the park as well.
Um, I mentioned earlier at the very beginning the observatory. That's a
project that started from the data centers for Meta. They made a donation And
that has led to getting a grant from
Utah County and from getting donations from UVU and some of their major
donors and more money coming in from Meta. And we finally have a fully funded
project to bring in an observatory into our community because of the dark skies that
we enjoy and tying that in with educational programming with our school
district and with our university.
As we've been doing our neighborhood tours, questions came up like, When's the Sweetwater
Community Park going to be completed? And so we've been answering those questions and working
with developers. Nolan Park improvements, phase 1, Nolan Park
splash pad. That the difference between Nolan Park splash pad and the splash
pad at Quarry Ride Park is one recirculates the water, and so it's a
good use of the water, but it's very expensive to do that.
And the other one's just the water goes right down the drain, and so it's
a poor use of water. And so if we're going to make Nolan Park splash
pad truly usable, we need to make it so that it's sustainable as well.
And then of course our Parks and Trails Master Plan and making sure that all
of our parks connect with trails and, and all the enhancements and making
sure our trails are properly managed so that we're not incompatible
uses and having e-bikes that are impacting walkers
and things like that. So there's a lot of code changes and restrictions and whatnot.
And of course open space management. We have a lot of open spaces that we
need to maintain, and the council's trying to evaluate what projects
makes most sense to enhance our open spaces and where open space
might be able to go back to ownership by the, um, by the neighboring parcels.
Um, with facilities, we know that our staff is a third of the size
of other city staffs, and yet we're, um,
we're basically, um, extremely tight in the office space that
we have, and we're leasing office space and paying for rental costs right now.
And so we're trying to create a temporary office space plan on how we can
continue to enhance and add more staff so that we can support the residents that
are coming to our community. But we're doing it in such a way that,
that, um, makes financial sense, that we own an asset at
the end, uh, because ultimately our long-term goal is to get our staff consolidated
in a new city hall, have a new downtown, a third space, uh,
where we can bring our community together. And so we're
working on new city hall downtown planning. We also have
things like our public works yard improvements, our north service area planning.
Um, there's desire for recreational venues. You know, all of those are enhancements
to the quality of life and, and their ability to serve the residents of Eagle
Mountain City. When it comes to things like public safety,
another high priority for us is to recognize that that public
safety not only is our most essential service, but we have to do it in
an affordable way. And so, um, as we are a taxing entity
with Unified Fire through UFSA,
and as our city's financial base is growing, we have to step
away from that and become a contract city like some of our other participating
cities so that we can responsibly do that and not put an overarching
and or high level of tax on our residents. And so we are
working on a conversion to step away from UFSA
but maintain the great relationship and the great services that UFA provides.
There's no doubt that they're the top, top-notch, high quality, and we,
we love having the work that UFA does for us. But let's do
it in such a way that as we add more data centers and more taxable
value, that we're not creating an undue burden on our residents.
We also have to look at our long-term public safety needs.
Does that mean remodeling this building? Does it mean including it in City
Hall in the future? And what does the future of
law enforcement mean? Right now, all of our law enforcement
is through an outsourced agreement with Utah County. And what
we don't recognize, and one of the things that they provide, is all of
their evidence storage, all of their training facilities,
all of their overhead, all of their, um,
um, uh, you know, exercise facilities,
anything that they have, their sally ports, their maintenance, their fleet, all that
type of thing, all takes place in Spanish Fork. If we were to do that
in-house, we would have to take on those costs and those burdens. And so we
have to figure that out. And we also have to work, work with the county
on a, on a very, on a wise transition plan,
uh, and do so in harmony that it's beneficial for all parties involved,
but most importantly for the residents we all serve.
Um, our public safety master plan is part of that with our IFFP and IFA
there. And then we have new things pop up like the Best Friends Animal Society
proposal that just came in last meeting. You know, it's another idea,
another great program. Um, how does that fit into the overall
view? As far as community development, I'm only—
I'm not even going to hit all the departments, but As far as community development,
I know that they're working very hard on water-wise landscaping codes.
They just spent time with our public works department and some
of our council learning about water-wise landscaping from
Utah State University and how we can make the
best use of our water moving forward. Trying to track our MDAs
to make sure that we all the requirements of developers are really being put in
by developers and having tools in place to build and help us.
Our general plan— so we have the guiding document of where we're going and
where would you want us to be as a community. Our rodeo grounds planning,
consideration of new plans for plan review software,
various code updates from the senior housing to the mining overlay to
seasonal signs to artificial turf. I mean, there's all sorts of things that are on
there. Their to-do plate. And then new things that come up like the Sage Valley
neighborhood sign that we want to be able to support not only for
Sage Valley but all for all of our communities as they are trying
to have greater and greater community pride.
As far as community services, or a lot of people call that leisure services,
that really gets into the setup of our community services board, how they're
going to be usually utilizing the wrap text. dollars and how they're going to be
enhancing the quality of life for our parks and trails and whatnot.
Great things are taking place with Eagle Mountain 30 and USA 250 events
this year, but we're trying to take in-house our soccer programs.
We're trying to look at our CITLA trails and make sure that we have legitimate
use of the trails in our community that people are enjoying
but don't necessarily have all the rights to as far as CITLA is concerned
or other private property. Steve tonight talked about
the Healthy Utah Initiative. We've talked about bringing other amenities to our community
like skate rinks and things like that because there's economic
opportunities and partnerships with Utah County and the private sector that
might be able to benefit our community. And just some of the things on administration,
everything from Justice Court to bulk garbage analysis to
customer advocacy department and setting that up to turn
to make sure that we're basically helping the customer from the moment they call all
the way through until they get resolution of their issue. We're trying to educate the
public with Citizens Academy and making sure that they're aware of all the things that
are going on that makes life better, worth living here in Eagle Mountain City.
I've talked about the leadership development program.
Intergovernmental relations and advocacy. You know, we get impacted by the state all
the time with league activities and and legislative
changes. And so there's a lot of work that goes into that.
Various land acquisitions and disposal. I didn't even touch water when it comes to all
the water rights and all that type of thing. Website upgrades, project enhancements,
project management software rollout so we can track all of this work.
So ultimately, that's really the end of the presentation.
Where I'd like to go right now is to get the council's direction on one
thing, um, from this list that is going to continue to evolve
and continue to flesh out. We can have the
council prioritize that list first and then have the staff take a crack
at it. We could have the staff and the council concurrently
rank it. But what I would recommend is that you
would allow the staff to rank the project by department. Now, not 1
to 200 of the projects that we have, but But, you know,
1 to 15 in the water department, 1 to 15 in the sewer
department or whatnot. You allow the staff to rank those out based
on what they consider the highest priority in their critical path items and whatnot,
and then send that to you so that you can then review that, make tweaks
as you see fit, and then set the final word. These are our priorities
moving forward. Because your insights might
push projects up or down on that list. But having the insight of knowing what
staff's recommending first is probably the best place to start. And so I'll leave
it to you. You tell us. We work for you. We work at the pleasure.
You tell us what you'd like us to do and how you want us to
do it. There was one other thing that I was going to mention too,
is that Mr. Magnus is here as well that helped with
that prioritization. He's worked— he works on our legislative priority
list. That's a whole other list that got moved into here. So we can have
him join in on any of this that you guys give direction on, but is
that the direction you want? Just have staff go ahead and rank this and then
we kind of weigh in on some of those? And one of this, you know,
like you've heard me say it before, it's like, well, what don't you want us
to do if we're going to add this? Because it just gets to be a—
Why are you looking at me? I'm just looking down at general diaspora.
Every idea is a good idea. We love them all. But it's, you know,
I mean, you kind of get— this was literally the top 4
or 5, and there's hundreds of things. So just an idea of the workload that
we're dealing with. And, uh, you know, we want to make sure that we're
doing things but not also chasing rabbits, is what we talked about too. So,
um, direction, insight?
I'm comfortable with the staff providing their recommendations. They're the ones
that are closest to the source, and I'd love to hear their
insights for sure. Yeah, I would agree with that.
And then maybe the council could provide some feedback to, you know,
we're probably going to be close where maybe they rank it number 1, but residents
would rank it number 2. So some— that might
be a good starting point to rank it and bring it back to the council,
and then we can tweak it, reorder a little bit.
Great. I'm sorry, Mayor. I was just—
and then there's some things that might not show up on the list, but we
know are deeper down there that you might want to move up into that top
15, right? That's, that's kind of the idea as well, that we can move
things forward. Go ahead. Um, I was just going to say, I think having
the information, like if we're at like a critical state, like we're at capacity for
a wastewater treatment plant or something like that, I think that needs to
be conveyed to us too as part of that prioritization.
So it's not just arbitrarily us choosing,
but we're given that additional information. You know, that, that's a— you make
a really good point. And I just look at just today alone. Today,
um, we're not only looking at, you know, the impacts of a property
tax increase on our finance department, but we're trying to,
to do bonding for the new sewer treatment plant. We're trying to bring in
the Smiths and the Kroger. We're trying to complete an audit. We're trying to
start another audit. And answer community questions all
at the same time. And so I think I look at the stress
level for the finance department
and it may not be high all the time, but this is probably one of
your higher weeks. You know, and I think that is probably true for
every department, right? There's times when the water system, you know,
Mac is just dying because all the water
system's falling apart all of a sudden. time. And so every department
goes through their pain.
First, Ben, thanks for providing this. And it's not even
an exhaustive list, what you sent out in the email. I think
that's really helpful. I think there are some things even that you put on what
you kind of brought here that I think ought to disappear, if I'm being completely
frank. Sure. And probably
because I And maybe the council will feel differently.
OK, well, some came from a previous council that may not be relevant anymore.
Well, I'll just give a very specific example, like the ice skating rink. I think
we pursued that to a degree and to a level, and in my opinion,
there's no sense chasing that. Maybe there is among the
rest of the council members, but so I like the idea of the staff evaluating
it, saying, look, these are the things that we think are most important, the most—
the top 15. We have the 200 to look at. look at and
to look at it and say, look, you guys missed this, or you missed this,
or you missed this. We think that this should have a higher priority. And then
we can have that, that discussion about those things.
And if there's anything I want to stress, we're all one team.
Oh yeah, for sure. 100%. We support you, and we feel like we're
in— we just want to be aligned. But I, but I also think there's wisdom
in, in allowing us to give some input so we're not chasing those rabbits.
The ice skating rink at least is one, in my opinion. I don't
think that we should be exhausting or using resources
to chase that. I think that there's a fairly definitive answer that today's not the
right time to pursue that. Now that's just my opinion, but at least
if we know that that's something that's still on your radar that you guys are
concerned about and that you've kind of felt some direction from the council or
the mayor, we ought to have that discussion and say let's dismiss that and get
it off your lives. Let me answer that one for just a second. So the
only reason that came up is because there was some donations that paid— almost paid
for it, just like the observatory. As those donations
and contributions kind of aren't fleshed
out, we're not working on it. Yeah, and I'm not saying it was inappropriate to
chase it. I think it was good to pursue it to gain an understanding.
But my understanding is at this point in time, that's kind of a worthless
chase, isn't it? Only if it's funded by outside sources. And that's where we're at.
So if it's funded, great. If it's not, then— Set it aside and forget about
it. Yeah. Well, and, and, you know, it's maybe just the timing's
not right. As soon as we get some of these needs, these foundational needs like
sewer and water worked out, then we might have time for things like recreational
improvements. I would say that I think it
would be helpful for us to understand time. Man-hours would be important
to be added to this. I think it would be good for us to Which
funding source would be utilized for this?
And then I think understanding time, because I'm looking through
this. I have been doing a lot of exercises with AI lately from
these types of things. So I love having this information here to
just go and show me the workload. Who's carrying it?
It's pretty interesting. Exercise to find out how many
projects have been placed on one individual person, which is why they're not getting done.
I mean, that's the reality of it. There's only a certain amount of time in
a day. And I think understanding the amount of time that
it's going to be to take that, what the cost of it's going to be,
how it's going to be funded, should be things that we should be prioritizing that
information. So if it's, you know, if it's something that's going to take 3 years,
it's probably not the highest priority for them to be spending every
minute of every day on. But I think we're probably out of the loop as
to what the timeframe for each of these things are. And when we make an
ask, it would be good to say, okay, if you're okay with that,
that's 30 man-hours. We don't have a person
to do 30 man-hours. So which project would you like
them to put on pause to accomplish that? And I think that gives us better
idea of what is important, what's not important.
Maybe to Brett's point, maybe some of these things that we have people chasing after
are really just dead ends and we need to get rid of them. I think
that's important too. A conversation we had is maybe if it's 30 man-hours and we
can see that we can't get to everything, maybe we need another guy. 'Cause we
can see the man-hours that we're not covering, right?
Anything else? Any input?
I think you— so— Can you maybe get the staff to prioritize
these, give us a little bit of a guess on man hours? And they will
flesh it out. I just took lists and consolidated them. Some of the departments aren't
fully fleshed out, so there's gonna be other things added to this. I guarantee it's
gonna go from 200 to 300. Every day new projects come up. Yep.
Okay, thank you. Perfect, thanks. I think that's
good insight on the workload, and I've been talking about it a lot
privately with each of you, that is, Man, we're busy and we all
know during the budget process we need staff and there's a lot to do.
But while you get back up here, the next items,
any updates? But I think that kind of covered it. Did you have anything on
top of that outside? I think that covered it pretty well. Okay,
then we'll go ahead and review some of the agenda,
specifically the closed session, or sorry, not closed session, the consent
agenda. There's some appointments
for the Youth Council. We've got the list Craig's been working on. I've seen over
here, so you guys have seen the entire Youth Council list, correct?
Any questions?
Miss Eagle Mountain is going to do an introduction. We have some minutes.
July 21st, we're good. Site plan with
the chapel and recreation building. We've We've seen this quite a bit recently.
Is there any other questions on that one?
And then an ordinance of Eagle Mountain City approving the same
site plan, the chapel and recreation building.
The development agreement. Yeah, development agreement, sorry.
Nothing on that one? Okay. Then a couple
scheduled items. If we— we do have a couple minutes if we can ask some
questions. Now, I don't know if Kiara's here.
Oh, this is public hearing. Oh yeah, yeah, that's just a public hearing only.
And then, uh, on the, uh, CBDG— CDBG
action plan. So we'll take care of that. And then the rezoning
of Scenic Mountain, which is just from a traditional, uh,
zone to our current zoning. Um,
any questions on that one? Any comments? need any information provided.
Mayor, Evan had his hand up just for a second. Oh,
okay. Probably back on the public hearing.
I'm just guessing.
Yeah, so we, um, just back on the CDBG public hearing,
um, we discovered that there was an issue with that agenda item.
It was not meant to be just a public hearing. There's supposed to be action
taken. Um, we're supposed to submit are planned
to HUD by August 18th.
And as far as we understand, there's not really any way— August 14th.
August 14th. Sorry. Yes, August 18th is the next council meeting.
August 14th. So we're kind of in a little bit of a
tough spot because as far as I understand, there's not anything we can do to
change the agenda tonight. So we wanted to
just ask if there's any possibility we could do some sort of a special council
meeting next week if we can get a quorum together just to approve the
plan. It'd be a very short agenda obviously, but that's
kind of the last thing that we're left with. Remote too? That's remote,
that's easy. Is that,
when are you thinking, Evan? What kind of
timeline are you seeing? Whenever we can get a quorum together really.
We just need 3 people to sign
off on it. So whatever is available for 3 people. Tuesday, Wednesday. It could be
virtual morning or lunch. Right, they could appear virtually.
It doesn't have to be after work hours.
Yeah. I'll make myself available.
I mean, I can— Wednesday is— I'm hearing a Wednesday. That would
be the 12th. Monday and Tuesday at noon are good for
me. Monday and Tuesday midday. Is Wednesday afternoon good as well?
Wednesday's better for me. Like 5,
6 o'clock Wednesday? Yeah, I can do Wednesday afternoon.
I can do that on Wednesday as well. So it sounds like
we'd at least have a quorum on Wednesday at 5, 6.
I can't do it in that late. Mine's earlier. So if somebody else wants to
do it. Damon starts football. Wednesday. What's the latest you can go for?
I could do earlier. I have like noon. Noon? I'm fine.
Which day? Wednesday. Yeah, I could do that,
especially if it's virtual. I can't do Wednesday noon,
but that's okay. What about Tuesday? I think it's important that,
'cause it's all of us making a decision about where we're spending those
dollars. So is there a time that we can find for everyone?
Or Tuesday? How about everyone's Tuesday?
Do we have Tuesday middle of day or Tuesday late afternoon? What are
we at? Tuesday I'm good 12 to 2. Okay, anyone else? 12 to 2
on Tuesday. Okay, what about
Thursday? Monday, hang on, Monday? Monday through Monday
afternoon. I can do Monday. Monday after 3.
Perfect. Okay, Monday after
3? All right, let's do it. There you have it. So Monday the 10th
at 3:30. Will you send an
invite please? Just so I can get it on my calendar and block it off.
It'll be a virtual 3:30 Monday.
Uh, I suppose Kiara or anybody that needs to be there could
also be there. You're gonna handle this? Yeah, Kiara and Elizabeth will help with that.
Okay, let's, let's put it on for Monday the 10th,
3:30. Send an— Lacey, would you
send an invite to council for that? And then we'll— So does the public hearing
still happen today then? Yes, it still needs to happen today. Yeah, I appreciate
you making that time, accommodating. Thanks. Okay,
thank you. All right, we already talked about the Scenic Mountain,
then, uh, the TMP, that's the Transportation Master
Plan, IFF Do you guys have questions specifically
on that that we could go over now before we? I've got questions on that,
but I think it's probably better with the larger presentation that's happening
anyway. I think it's a. I don't know if we want to dive into that
now. It's almost six o'clock. Okay, so we'll wait on
that one. I am going to try something a little bit different because it's we
have just a second. The legislative priority list item seventeen.
A lot of times we keep. Mr. Magnus here till wee hours
of the night, and if there's anything— if we need to make any motions,
we'll have to do that later. But at least we could— if there's not,
we could cut him loose a lot earlier than we normally do,
although I know he loves staying with us.
So maybe we can knock out some legislative priority,
anything on the list, and then— So we haven't
knocked anything on the list. It's pretty short these days. days. I still
owe you the list for the state legislative. What I've been doing
is going through all the minutes and agendas for
all the interim committees. I finished that today, so I'll send
that out so you know what's been happening at the state level,
plus the other list that we talked about. I'll get those out and start meeting
with you guys. Right now it looks like water is going to take top priority
just because of the drought, and then followed by housing. Thank you. So those
are the 2 areas that I'm seeing there's a lot of discussion and movement on.
So that's at the state level.
Internally with the city, we're still working on things. I'm still trying to get the
people with the poured concrete fences to return my
phone calls. So as soon as I get that done,
I'll get ahold of you, Councilmember Woods, and start working on the design.
So I have one item. I had a builder approach me wondering
if we can get more ladder signs. And I know, Councilmember Clark, I think there
was something you were pursuing with wanting more ladder signs.
I don't know what even the process is for that. This is me wearing
a different hat. So, um, I know that the
chamber has submitted something with Mr. Salazar and
has CC'd you on it and Abby Ivory, and I will
let you guys communicate with the chamber staff instead of me about the
signs, if that helps. What would the process be? So if, if a builder
is asking for more— So I'll talk to you about code. Our code right now
limits the number, and it requires that the map has to get
brought back to the city council for approval
every single time something changes. If there were going to be additional
sign locations added, it would need to be either the
city council approves it every single time, or there's a code change made to change
it so that maybe city engineer and economic development
make decisions about where new locations can go. Okay, 'cause the
issue we're running into is on the south side of Cedar Valley, we're having new
construction happen and newer subdivisions going in down there and probably inadequate
signage that didn't contemplate the new— well, new growth's happening down
there, but our current signage is probably insufficient.
Hannah is ready to talk to you all about it. So if you want to
reach out to her tomorrow, she'll be able to fill you in all the details.
So I've heard— I don't know that all council members are in
favor of increasing those ladder signs. However, when we're talking about the
expansion toward the south end, does that change? For me,
I think that if we're going to consider that, that we ought to have a
work session discussion about it and a presentation about where those areas I
would be in favor of
that. So I think rather than— what I'm gathering, rather than a legislative priority
or on John's radar, it's more something that we've got to talk about as a
discussion item or something. Yeah, I think so, because I think part
of that discussion has to be if we're creating this because developers are asking for
it, there probably needs to be a clock on these signs so that they aren't
there forevermore. Because there's a lot that
are already in our city, and once the building stops, then what?
Well, I think a heat map so that we kind of look at it and
say, look, we have this type of density in this area, and so that there's
some, at least some equalization of that citywide. And I think that may be what
you're referencing, Craig. That's why I just think it's a broader
discussion, because if it's, if it's just can we raise the number to this number,
my answer is going to be no. If there's data to support it that
says, look, in this area we have a saturation rate of X,
but in this area we don't have any signs at all and there's a need
to approve some in this area, that's, that's a discussion I'm willing to have.
So I think some of those new areas would be the south of the city,
but also Firefly. I don't remember if there's any signs out there. Look, we're growing
all over the place, and so I think we ought to be willing to have
the conversation, but I think it needs to be data-driven.
I didn't have anything to add to Craig. I think that's a good idea.
The one thing that I had brought to Evan was regarding trailers.
I'm wondering if we could bring that back in a work session regarding multiple parking,
multiple trailers. I'm going to say on
like mid-range lots, half acre to acre, where people
are stacking 3, 4, 5 RV trailers,
it's obviously a business. And I'm just wondering if— I know that's
come up to the council before, but I think we haven't landed
on a solution and we need to find a solution, whether that's better
screening. Maybe one trailer can be publicly visible,
but the other 5 need to be screened away from
view. We've got that going on, I think, about 4 or 5
properties in my own neighborhood. And I would imagine it's probably happening throughout
the city in other areas.
So what I'm hearing, Lacey, is if you'll add for upcoming items,
uh, the trailer parking code that I know we've worked on in the past— is
that— was it trailer? Just for discussion? Yeah, for discussion items. And then,
uh, in work session, and then the, uh, potential locations
for ladder signs, we can get Hannah to Do a presentation
or let us know where we're deficient on that, with the help
of staff if that's needed. If is the presentation from
the chamber sufficient on that?
Is that probably? Is that I can make sure that the staff knows
that they need to prepare a heat map and some of the things that you
guys have asked for. At the chamber is what she means.
You mean the staff at the chamber? Yes. Okay, I just wanted to clarify.
I'll convey that message to them. Yeah, I just didn't
want our staff saying, okay, there's 205 on my list now.
So is there anything else, legislative priorities, that we need to put on John's radar
for today? Nothing?
Okay, then we do have a couple closed session items
that we could take care of. I know Craig's ready to make a motion.
I move the City Council adjourn to a closed session pursuant to Section 52-4-205,
subsection 1 of the Utah Code Annotated. Second. Okay,
we have a motion by Councilmember Whiting and a second by Councilmember Wood,
right? Uh, start the vote with Councilmember Hughes. Yes. Councilmember Wood.
Yes. Councilmember Whiting. Yes. Councilmember Wright. Yes. Councilmember Clark.
Yes. Okay, at 6:06, we'll adjourn to closed session.
In the name of Jesus Christ, amen. Amen.
Okay, we'll go ahead and call this policy
session to order at 7:05. And, uh,
as we get started, we've asked our Miss Eagle Mountain 2026,
Trias, to lead us in the Pledge of Allegiance.
Please join me in the Pledge of Allegiance. I pledge allegiance
to the flag of the United States of America,
And to the republic for which it stands, one nation
under God, indivisible, with liberty and justice for
All right. Mr. Reeves,
do we have any public information items? We do.
Yes. One more, Mayor. Our Youth City Council is having their
Summer Splash event tomorrow, Wednesday,
August 5th, from 2 to 4 PM at Corey Ride Memorial Park.
If you want a chance to dunk your favorite council member,
you can certainly come out and do that in our dunk tank.
Truth in Taxation public hearing will be Thursday,
August 6th, at 6 PM here at City Hall in the chambers.
Farmers Market is every Saturday from 9 to 1 PM through October
10th at Glory Ride Park. And then there's another event, Ties and Tiaras,
this Saturday— or on Saturday, August 15th at 7
PM at the Overland Barn. If you guys have
never seen Councilmember Wright dress up in a— I don't even know the old rockers—
a wig that looks like Jimi Hendrix.
Yeah, I look good with hair, let me tell you that.
Come to the Youth Council. I was wondering why they were all here to support
Duncan Councilmember Wright, right? All right,
moving right along. We do have our entire Youth Council here,
most of them, and they will get sworn in today. So how this is going
to work, we're gonna make a couple motions, then we have to vote. No telling
where that's going to go. And then we'll call all of you forward, do the
mayor first, right, Lacey? Or did you want to do them all together? Mayor first
and then the rest of the council together. Okay, so that's the way we'll do
this. And, uh, with that, I think Councilmember Whiting's got a
motion. It's my honor to move to approve KJ
Call as the Youth Council Mayor until the— for a term
until the next Youth Council election in 2027.
Second. Okay, we have a motion by Councilmember Whiting,
a second by Councilmember Wood. We'll start the vote with Councilmember Clark. Yes.
Councilmember Wright? Yes. Councilmember Whiting? Yes. Councilmember Wood?
Yes. And Councilmember Herwish? Yes. Okay.
The Youth Council? And it's also my honor to move
to approve the following individuals as Youth Council committee members: Sophia
Anderson, Eliza Byrd, Elena Call, Cora Davis,
Jordan Deinhart, Hinckley Franco, Kali Franco,
Raina Howell, Carly Jackson, Lexi Jackson, Ryker Jackson,
Xander Jackson, Lily Messerly, Sarah Ortega,
Abigail Pace, Darcy Washburn, and Lucy Washburn,
and, uh, for a term until the next Youth Council election in 2027.
Second. Okay, we have a motion again by Council Member Whiting,
a second by Council Member Wood. Council Member Wright? Yes. Council Member
Whiting? Yes. Council Member Wood? Yes. Council Member Huish? Yes.
Councilmember Clark? Yes. Perfect. We'll bring the mayor up and,
uh, Lacey will go over there and we're going to come
down and so we can congratulate everybody at the end. So when they're done,
all the Youth Council that was, uh, okay.
Oh yeah, everybody come up then. That's, that's why I was asking. So everybody at
the same time. Yeah, and we're gonna come— no,
let's do the picture from up here. Yeah, we'll stay up here and we'll do
a picture after.
All right, we're gonna have you guys just squeeze in a little bit right here.
Our photographer for the city is gonna get right
there. We're gonna get a nice little picture, so get close together.
Not you.
Lacey, do they need to sign the— They have their oaths
of office. They can sign them and take them home.
Okay, thanks guys. Appreciate your willingness to serve.
Okay, we've got another cool recognition that
we'll get another picture for here in just a second, but it's our honor
to introduce our 2026 Miss Eagle Mountain.
We'll have you guys come up and state your
names, tell us a little something you think we need to hear, and then do
the same thing. We'll turn around up here and get a picture.
Go ahead to the microphone up here.
Good evening, my name is Emmeline Smith and I'm honored to serve this year as
Miss Teen Eagle Mountain's first runner-up. Through my community service initiative,
Life Lifesavers in Training, I plan to teach kids, teens, and adults basic
first aid and emergency response skills so they can feel more prepared when in
an emergency. I'm excited to represent Eagle Mountain
this year through this community that has already given me so much.
Thank you.
Good evening, City Council members. My name is Brighton Hawes, and I'm honored to serve
as Eagle Mountain's teen. My CSI is called Generation
for Wildlife, and it's about educating the youth on the importance of preservation
and conservation of wildlife. I'm excited for this year, and I think
it's going to be great. Thank you.
Mine's a little longer, so I'm going to warn you. Good evening, Mayor and City
Council. For those of you who don't know me, my name is Treea Smith,
and I'm so, so honored to be able to be crowned
Miss Eagle Mountain of 20— for 2026. This was my 5th year competing
for the title, so standing here today truly is such a dream come true,
and I could not be more grateful for the opportunity that has fallen into my
hands this year. This year, my community service initiative
is Red, White, and Your Rights, which focuses on civic engagement
among young voters. As many of you know, the voter turnout in Eagle Mountain is
severely low. So my goal this year is to
help young adults register to vote, know how candidates
get on a ballot, and also know how to participate
in the voting process. Local government impacts our everyday life, and I
believe being informed in voting is one of the most meaningful ways
that we can truly make a difference. We've already had so much fun
and an incredible start to the year. We have
been going to events, working alongside Don and Dave,
and getting to meet so many amazing families, local businesses, and community members.
Every event has reminded me why I love Eagle Mountain so much.
Thank you guys for allowing me the opportunity to serve this amazing city,
and I look forward to working alongside of each of you this year and to
represent Eagle Mountain with pride. Thank you so, so much.
Thank you.
So I'm going to have you guys turn around. We're going to do a little
more this way because we always get the podium right in our way. So let's
squeeze this way, turn around, and we'll get a picture, and then we'll go on.
You want to be in the picture too?
I'll let you go first.
Okay, everyone look at me, please.
Thank you very much.
All right.
That's kind of the fun part of the job. We get to do that kind
of stuff. And this is another thing that we actually look forward to. We've got
time set aside for the the public to make general public comment.
This time has been set aside for public— for the public to express their ideas,
concerns, and comments. Please limit your comments to 3 minutes
each. I will allow the public— I will now open
the public comment period at 7:16.
As a reminder, public comment is an opportunity for community members to address the City
Council, and each speaker is allowed 3 minutes. If you wish to speak during
the public hearing portion, please complete
a comment form located in the back. They're on the table back there,
and return it to our city recorder on this side over here.
Council members will listen but not engage in discussion during public
comment. Disruptive behavior, personal attacks, or comments about
individual city employees are not permitted. If you have issues or questions regarding
staff or personnel, our administrative staff will meet you in the
foyer to discuss that, uh, for further discussion.
Lastly, public comment period is for items not associated with a scheduled public hearing.
If your comments relate to a public hearing item, please wait until the item is
called. For information, tonight's public hearing items are,
uh, the programmed 2026 HUD CDBG
Annual Action Plan. Uh, there's an ordinance
of Eagle Mountain City, Utah, rezoning certain lands known as scenic Mountain,
and then 15B, an ordinance of Eagle Mountain City amending the master plan
known as the Master Transportation Plan, TMP,
and Impact Fee Facilities Plan. So those are the public hearings.
If there's anything else that you'd like to talk about, uh,
we have 3 minutes. Lacey Duncan Searcy.
I got to go first. Dang it, I thought surely somebody else would
I don't know if you want to go first before me. All right. I'm DJ,
more commonly known as Duncan Searcy. I've missed you
guys. It's been a little while since I've been to one of these, so I
thought I'd come harass you. No, I'm going to be pretty nice. I want to
talk a little bit about your proposed property tax increase, the reasons for
doing it, and ask some questions, and then just inform you guys a little
bit about what's going on in the life of the regular
Eagan Eagle Mountaineer. Eagle Mountaineer, okay? So,
220% is a lot. We will start there. Even if
it's just $1 a day, for some of your citizens, that's 1 to 5%
of their annual income, okay? So, that's,
that's not a small chunk of change to some of us, some of us poor
folk, okay? The other thing I want to mention is more
of your neighbors than you realize are living paycheck
to paycheck right now. Another good chunk, less hopefully,
are living credit card payment to credit card payment. Every time
you do anything to raise taxes, there's going to be
effects, especially on our pensioners. They've earned what they have.
If we're raising the property taxes on them, perhaps they moved here 15 years ago,
and that was one of the calls to move out here to Eagle Mountain,
is they saw the low property taxes. Okay, I do not
think it is the job of the citizens to shoulder
the burden of bad decisions past
and present council city planning has made and force
us to come up with those funds. We are growing rapidly. There should
be a commensurate amount of tax increase there as well.
Mayor Jarrett, when he was campaigning on the trail, he talked
a lot about the different things that are coming, and we're going to have so
much money we don't know what to do with. So maybe let's hold off on
the property tax increase, wait for some of those investments
to come, put the city hall on the back burner, some of these other
things, while your citizens are really struggling financially.
The other thing that I was going to say about all that is
I think another reason the citizens are upset is the way it was
framed. You guys are like, law enforcement, we love law enforcement, we need
to increase that. But we had to find out in the comments that
it was also for capital projects, and that wasn't defined anywhere,
at least initially. And so it's kind of a bait and switch when you say
we need to raise taxes so we have law enforcement, because who doesn't
want a good amount of law enforcement? We want to be safe, right? So I
felt like that was a little bit dishonest. 10 seconds remaining. And it rubbed people
the wrong way there. So I think a little bit
more transparency would do you well. I feel
safe here. You know, I know they want more deputies. I genuinely
don't feel threatened for my life. And if there's anybody here
that has death threats, you know, that's me. So I think
when we see so many patrol cars at a traffic
stop, you know, 2, 3, 4, from the citizen's
perspective, it doesn't look like we really need more law enforcement. Your time
is up. Thank you. All right, thank you. Thank you.
That's it.
Was there anyone else here who did not have the opportunity to make public
comment that would like to? Seeing no one, we will close
the public comment period at 7:19 and
bring it back to the council for comments to
the public. And I'm going to switch sides. We're going to go with Rich first.
Rich Wood. Great to see
so many people here, especially those here to support the Youth Council.
We appreciate their willingness to get involved at an early age to understand
how government works. I love the way that we changed
it to make it available for so many people to participate on the council.
So it was great having them all up
here. I'm a little envious, Jesse. I hope it's awesome
this year for you guys. Appreciate the comments,
DJ. Always appreciate you coming and speaking your mind. That's the point
of public comments. I'm gonna tell you, I don't think that
you're totally wrong. I think that we could have done a better job in some
of the ways that it was presented. I look forward to being able to talk
about that on Thursday and maybe providing some
clarity, 'cause I agree. I think that it's not clear. So we're going to try
to do a better job of getting that information so that it's clear. May not
agree, but the reality of it is, is we need to be crystal clear.
Councilmember Whiting. I'm so proud of the youth
that are taking their time to be engaged and make
a difference. And we saw that with our Youth Council. We see that with our—
also with the pageants, and so awesome.
There's a lot of energy with Youth Council, and it's really— I'm really honored to
be the liaison from the City Council to be a part of your group,
and looking forward to the activity that's going to happen tomorrow, even though I'm going
to get wet and it's going to be cold. But really grateful.
I mean, Eagle Mountain City has some of the most
amazing youth, and I know it's a priority among the City Council to Create
an environment here in which they can engage and learn, and there's a
lot that's that we're dealing with to help keep them safe, help our
roads improve. And so I won't go into the depth
of all of what we need to continue to do to help this be the
most amazing place ever for for the youth. Also,
DJ, thanks for your comments, and we we appreciate you, you know,
coming and sharing. And I will say,
we could say in some ways, you know, what you mentioned
about the money coming in eventually, that is true. And Mayor Gray did make
comments that, you know, as data center money matures, it will come in.
But I was also there many times when he said the next 4 years are
probably going to be the most— the toughest years. And he also said, I'm probably
going to be a one-term mayor, even if he wants a second term,
because of the challenging decisions we're going to have to make during these current
4 years because the data center money isn't here
yet. And it's going to start maturing. It's going to start coming here.
But we, you know, looking at the different things we got going on,
we may have to make some unpopular decisions. And hopefully a lot of
people show up on Thursday night. Hopefully we hear a lot of commentary from a
lot of people because we want to hear what your thoughts are and what you're
experiencing and what— yeah, your various thoughts and
feelings. Please Please come on Thursday night. We want a big crowd, we want a
lot of comments, and we're here to listen. So hopefully
people show up and participate.
Thanks, Mayor. Welcome, KJ. I just want to congratulate
you, or should I say Mayor Call? Let me start there.
That's quite an achievement. I'm really proud of you, and having had the opportunity to
work with the Youth Council last year, I'm I'm impressed
with the recruiting that you've been about. So thank you to
you and your advisors, your mother, and those other young men and young
women that have been participating there. It's fun to see the Youth Council grow,
and I will be there tomorrow if I can find my hair, okay? I mean,
I gotta find my wig so that I can come and you guys can dunk
me again. But I don't know if I'm gonna last as long as last year.
You guys beat me up bad, but I enjoyed it.
I really did. You really are the future of Eagle Mountain.
I love listening to the, to the,
to Miss Eagle Mountain and Miss Teen Eagle Mountain
as they talked about at least one of the CSIs. What do they call them?
Community initiatives. Okay, about the
wildlife and nature. And for me, that's really cool that
our youth are picking up that torch and, and moving forward with it.
So anything that I can do or anything that we can do as a council
to help you all be successful and prepare you for adulthood,
I'm happy to do that. I just want to express gratitude for
our staff and for the work that they do, for the incredible burdens that they
carry. If you joined us in work session, you got just a small taste
of what they deal with on a daily basis, and it's a—
it's an inexhaustible list of things that they have
to tackle every day, and I'm really grateful for their energy and for their effort
that they put forth. I'm grateful for the fellow council members that I sit here
with. We are called upon to make some pretty, pretty nasty
decisions. I don't know how else to say it. They're difficult, they're heavy,
and I think it can best be described as there's a loneliness to leadership.
When we ask for the opportunity to serve and to lead,
it comes with a duty, a responsibility, a burden,
and, and, and there's some honor and a blessing associated with it. But all of
those things are present in the decisions that we make.
And there's an accountability that each of us must have.
And I think we can do better, DJ. Our communication could be better.
I'm probably the worst communicator of all,
unless you sit down with me across the table, and then I'll communicate you to
death and you'll think I need a break. You'd be like,
shut up, Brett, I'm ready to move on.
But I just want to express my love and gratitude to those of you that
have showed up today. I appreciate that, and I look forward to listening to what
the citizens have to say on Thursday. Thank you.
I too am super excited to see you be our youth mayor. I've seen you
for years as I've come to Cedar Valley High School and seen
you grow into student council and all sorts of
other things, and I love that you and your colleagues are willing to serve our
community and the other kids in our community. It's about
time that Eagle Mountain has a youth council that's not embarrassingly small,
and I'm super excited for that. And I'm really grateful for the
young ladies that represent us as our city royalty. They're some
pretty incredible young ladies, and they do really neat things in our community,
so I'm grateful for them as well. This last Friday was
our 28th wedding anniversary. My husband and I have been married for 28 years.
And the day after that was my husband's birthday, and we got to go to
see Spider-Man. That was like a big deal. And it's
like the 12th Spider-Man. I don't even know. But as I
was watching the movie, there's this line in Spider-Man that
is kind of quintessential Spider-Man, and it says, with great power comes great
responsibility. And I think one of the greatest powers that any human could be given
is to tax another human being.
It's your property. You worked hard to bring it home.
You use it to take care of your family. And we don't take that
responsibility lightly.
Thank you.
I want you to know that as we prepare to make this decision
as a council, that we're thinking about you. We're thinking
about your individual circumstances, and we're trying to do right
by you and all of the residents of Eagle Mountain.
And we take that responsibility really seriously.
So thank you for being here today, and thank you for sharing your
viewpoints. And I look forward to hearing all the
ideas and insights and concerns on Thursday
so that we can make this decision together.
Thank you.
Thanks everyone for being here today.
To the Miss Eagle Mountain, they— it looks like they left. My daughter served
as a Teen Eagle Mountain, Miss Eagle Mountain Teen.
in 2019, and they— she served 2 years because
of the pandemic. They didn't have another one, so she got to go 2
years, and it just like was never-ending thing. But it was a real, a real
blessing for her and our family. Mayor,
Mayor Call, congratulations. That's awesome. Did you
speak at our memorial service? Yes. That was an awesome speech that you gave.
I just wanted to mention that to you again publicly. That was really
impressive. And not a surprise that you're serving as our youth mayor.
So congratulations. That's awesome. I know, I know our youth council will be
led well. DJ, thank you for being
here. I think the more heads we have,
the more comments, the more ideas, the better decision that we're going to make.
It is— I'm not having any fun. I spent most
of my weekend going back through every budget session that we
are already have sat through and copied every
dollar that was presented, gave it
a name, put it in a spreadsheet. I've been through it several times,
and I just want you to know that I take this decision pretty seriously,
and I know that my fellow council members do. It wasn't long ago
that my wife and I, if I had a $10 expense, I would call her
and say, hey, do we have that in our bank account? Can I go to
lunch today, or are we packing lunches? And we have 2
Title I schools in our city that are
paycheck to paycheck. And for many people, they won't be asking
for assistance. They'll probably just cut their savings or put
it on the credit card. And so we have a serious,
serious decision to make on Thursday, and I am confident that we'll strike
the right balance, both for the residents, for the city, and for
the need. We just sat through a presentation with Ben,
our city administrator. We have over 100 projects going on
in the city, and these aren't just light fixing a curb
or, or, um, you know, putting tar in a road. These are
like major infrastructure projects
that are going on, and they're not, they're not inexpensive. We're the 9th fastest growing
city in America, in the United States.
And when you start to dig down and look at all of the projects that
are happening with 2/3 or 1/3 of the staff
of other cities of our same size, it's pretty impressive.
It's a miracle in my mind that this city is even like operating.
I just applaud our staff. They do an amazing job. And prior
to January of this year, I was totally oblivious to all the things that were
happening. And now that I'm immersed in it,
it's pretty impressive. So I'm
confident we'll find the right balance.
And I appreciate the emails. I've had several that have come through.
I'm reading through them, I'm documenting them,
and we're gonna make the right decision,
the best decision that we can. So thank
you. Okay. I'll say that was 100
capital or construction projects. There's almost 400
total projects with initiatives and— Right, that's a lot, right?
Heavy lift. So yeah, it's,
it's, uh, I'll just add just briefly, the Youth Council came in
a couple weeks ago and I don't know if you say challenged me
to the hot wing challenge or something like that, right? It's just fun being in
the position that I get to meet with the youth as well every now and
again and some of the other organizations in the city and spend some time.
And man, we've got some really fun youth. They ask some hard questions. Most of
them I didn't know the answers to. I didn't even know who my superhero was
or whatever it's called because I don't watch Marvel or something.
But anyway, there were some hard questions. But what did
I say wrong? Because I don't know. But probably
a cowboy, Mayor. It's probably a cowboy of some sort. Ask me about bull riding.
Yeah, breeds of horses or something. I could have got that right. But, and the
queens too. I've been able to take them on carriage rides throughout
the year and different things. Just working with them is super fun.
So good times. And we appreciate all those that
come out and express their opinions and get to enjoy and
participate in the process. It's an honor for us. So thanks for everyone who's here.
And, and it's time to get to work. So the
first item we went through in our work session is the consent agenda.
Would you entertain a motion, Mayor? Yes. Mayor, I move that
the City Council approve the consent agenda. Second.
Okay, we have a motion by Councilmember Clark and a second by Councilmember Wright,
and we'll start the voting with Councilmember Whiting. Yes.
Councilmember Wood. Yes. Councilmember Hewish. Yes. Councilmember Clark.
Yes. Councilmember Wright. Yes.
Okay. Now our scheduled items. The first one is a public
hearing. I will note that this item
does need some action prior to our next meeting. So as
a council in our work session, we have decided to call a special meeting on
August 10th, Monday the 10th
at 3:30. It'll be a virtual meeting. It was only this
item. As of right now, and we'll address this funding.
But for tonight, we will have the public hearing so that we can move forward
with some action items on Monday. With that,
do you have a presentation? No presentation?
OK. Does the council have any questions specific to this item?
I think— Yeah,
just for the public's sake, you want to just lay out
us know what it is, that kind of an idea of what's going on,
so they, uh, and then we'll open the public hearing. This is the CBDG,
CDBG funding that, uh, is allocated from the county,
from HUD, uh, and some of the ways that we could spend this money that
qualify. Yep. Um, so good evening. Thank you, Mayor and Council,
and we really appreciate you guys putting us on a special meeting next week.
Um, so this meeting is just a formality
to fulfill this second public hearing and to give folks a chance to chime
in on any city projects that they might have comments on.
So— Perfect. Thanks. And I'll
read this because it helps some— we say CDBG all the time, and I don't
know if everybody knows what that means. It's Community Development Block Grant Program through HUD.
It provides federal funding for eligible community development activities.
As a condition of receiving the CDBG funds, the city must
annually adopt and submit annual action plan identifying the
proposed use of the allocation to hold up to 2 public hearings. So that's this
one, the second public hearing, and receive public input. Uh, the first
public hearing was held on April 7th, uh, and this one fulfills the second requirement.
Just so that we know what this is about, because I don't know if anyone's
here to speak on that, so at this time, uh, 7:36,
we'll open the public hearing, and it sounds like there is someone. Charlotte Dukos.
Turn the mic on, please. Oh yes. There you go. It was on.
All right, Charlotte Dukos. I'm just here to talk about the Community Development Block
Grant because I was having a conversation with principal over
at Cedar Valley High School. We got some news this week that we are opening
a— I'm gonna give it the name that he— I
got permission to talk about it. Eagle Mountain Community Center focused
on families. At Cedar Valley, we are planning
to and wanting to convert one of the sections of
one of our portables into a community center.
One of the things that we would like to do as a capital project is
to put in showers. The goal over
time is to have this available to the community, not just to school parents,
patrons, but to the community at extended hours and
to have shower facilities, pantry items. We would love
to have adult ed, things like that in that space. I know the
city has been looking for a space like that on the Community Services Board.
We've talked about that, so I was really excited to hear that that was
something that he was planning on and working on at
Cedar Valley. So as we consider these funds, would love to have that
project considered for some of the capital needs in
order to make that happen. And so I just wanted to put that on public
record, and I think it would be a really great use of those funds.
It would help both our low-income and,
you know, several other groups to help provide
those services that they need. So just wanted to make that option available as
far as the funding is concerned. And, um, thank you for your time.
Mayor, would it be okay,
um, finish the public hearing? So is there anyone else? Lacy?
That was it? Okay. All right, thank you. Uh,
seeing no one else— is there anyone else that came to speak on this item?
Seeing no one, uh,
7:37, we'll close the public hearing. And, uh,
Councilman Woods has was first and they'll come here.
I just wanted to ask the question, if first of all, does that qualify
where it's attached to a school? Because I think it's a great idea, by the
way. And then can we help them to get
an application put together quickly so that that can be something to be considered?
It could possibly qualify. We'd want to get some additional information
and, you know, look at eligible activities, but I think it
is a great opportunity to really serve
a vulnerable portion of the community in Eagle Mountain City.
So I think exploring that would be great,
and we can do kind of a simplified
application to just get some program information
and then really drill down to see if it could work.
Thanks. And it would qualify as a public facility.
Okay. One, I was wondering if Charlotte had
an idea of what the target ask is dollar-wise.
Do you know? Okay. And then this is more
for the two of you. If there are construction
building tradespeople within our community,
especially some of the really If we had a big entity that are benefiting
from being able to build here and they wanted to donate
time or do an in-kind donation of some sort, is there anything about
that that would jeopardize being able to use the other funding?
It's not likely that it would jeopardize anything as long as they're qualified
contractors who would be doing the work. So that would be
a great way to leverage funding. If you had community
members who wanted to support that. And again,
we can have a larger discussion as we drill down on
any discrete activities. So in the annual action plan,
we have the buckets. We don't have the actual discrete
activities that will be funded. But this one sounds like just a fantastic
opportunity. Yeah. OK,
go ahead. Just a quick question. And so I think you kind of answered
what my question was. What I'm seeing is in public facilities and infrastructure
improvements, there's about $181,000 that is kind of in that
bucket, $200,000 in affordable housing, and then under
the public services, $36,900. And is
that the way that's broken down? Just those 3? That's what
I see— I'm seeing in there. Does that sound right? There's administration and
planning Planning that also, but it's, it's not an actual
project. And so as we consider this on Monday, as this
comes back to us for an actionable vote of
some sort, is that really what you're asking, is that we, that we
kind of put it into these 3 buckets and be OK with that,
recognizing that there's still going to be some tightening up in each of those buckets?
Exactly. And how does that happen? When, when will that happen? And How
will we be informed? Will we be a party to that? How does that happen?
As discrete activities come up with the spending,
I think those agreements would come before council for approval.
Yeah. Okay, that's all I wanted, just to understand the process of that. So that's
perfect, thank you. And if we need, just to kind of answer, I think part
of that question, if there needs to be some flexibility, there's a small amount of
flexibility to move things between buckets right now, but if
we need to move larger amounts between buckets, we can
do an amendment to the plan. So, you know, that's a possibility.
Takes a little bit of time, but it's definitely doable.
Okay, perfect. I was just gonna note for the record when Melissa asked the question
that Charlotte Duco shook her head no. So that was
an answer that wasn't audible, but, and then as far
as the And then the, uh, also just ask you
ladies if you'd get with Charlotte either after or pull into the hall and get
some contact information for either the principal or whoever it is that we need to
get with to, uh, get further information
or an application. So if you guys will handle that. Uh, is there any other
comments or questions on this one? Okay, thank you. Thank you,
Council. No action tonight on that one, so we'll,
we'll come back and meet on Monday. And we will go to the next item.
It's 16A, an ordinance of Eagle Mountain City rezoning
certain lands known as Scenic Mountain. There is—
where's Robert Hobbs? Did I lose him? I'm going
to take this one.
We've done this before traditionally.
It should be pretty simple, I think. Yeah, I think so.
Let me drag this over. Just to kind of give the public a
little— You're good. Oh, there we go. I'm looking at the wrong thing.
Yeah, this has been through Planning Commission and Council a
little bit, so I think you're well aware of this. And for the
public's sake, we're going— Planning's going through the process of trying
to update the zoning map. There's a number of areas in our city
that have old zones that don't exist on books anymore. So we're
trying to go through and identify the areas that have those old zones and
then find those areas and
then update them to a current zone that matches with our current city
code.
Part of the reason why is if the public calls and
they've got these old zones, they want like,
hey, how far can I build this shed off my property line,
that, you know, it's a little harder for us to give them information
if they've got an old zone. We have to go dig back in
the old books and old versions of the code and find out what the setbacks
were and so forth. So this helps— this
proposal helps staff to be able to administer
land use application, help the public a little better. just makes
things, land use and zoning,
flow a little better in the city. So this is the
property we're looking at, 200 and change parcels over
in the scenic mountain area.
And so aerial photo there, and you can see the— this
is our general plan map. General plan just sets forth
our land use designations for our cities, whether it's residential,
commercial, so forth. So you can see that,
you can see the designation for that area.
And so I guess I need to be clear,
this is not only a rezone, but it's a,
not only a zone map amendment, but it's also an
amendment of our general plan 'cause we need to update Update
this map. It looks like we're we're showing some commercial
and and that that isn't accurate.
So what right now current
zoning's calling out multi-family,
calling out some old residential
zones from from an old agreement with the city. Those zones
don't exist anymore. So again, bringing this to current
zones, you can see our multifamily 1 and 2
zones are noted there in a kind of faint
yellow and a little bit brighter yellow.
Green is open space. There's a church
down in the blue that's being addressed. So planning,
So this has been to the Planning Commission. They've recommended approval.
Staff recommends approval of this. Again, this is just a cleanup,
just to make sure that we are able to utilize
the current codes in our current version of our
city code.
Okay. Are there any questions? I'll start with a question, actually,
because you mentioned the There was some commercial, but there isn't now. Is that right?
Yeah, as I'm looking, the, the part that
wasn't developed, this stuff, uh, went away.
Is it— has it been purchased already?
That part I don't— Isn't that triangle all UDOT land?
It's on the north end of Scenic Mountain.
There's a big chunk of it. is, right? This north of the townhouses?
This should be— one more time with your question, I'm sorry.
The north end of that triangle, if you go to your— back
to your proposed zoning,
the portion of that green area,
isn't most of that in the UDOT right-of-way?
It appears to be, yeah. There's 3 parcels. So Jared's
question was, is that commercial area? It appears
to be on the general plan map, yep. So that
was commercial and now is UDOT, correct? Yes. Okay, that's,
that's what I was trying to clarify. Yep, exactly. So was that your same question?
No, my question is, I mean, recognizing that you have
the zoning designation spelled out pretty clearly in the zone map.
The question I have is, what does the general plan amendment need to say?
What's it being changed from? What's it being changed to?
The general plan amendment is—
pull this back up. And,
you know, if you need to work through that, Brandon, for a minute, that's fine.
I'm just thinking in terms terms of a motion, and maybe we could do the
public hearing and then come back to that. But I'm not certain what it
is that we're, that we're considering changing it from and what it needs to be
changed to in the general plan. The zone is pretty— it's
very clear, but for me it's a little bit ambiguous about the general plan amendment
that we're considering.
Aren't the 2 properties, like the single-family homes and the, and the
townhomes, 2 different zones?
Yes, they they are. So that motion's got to be two different categories.
There are two different categories, and I agree with you that
I don't feel like we really are spelling that out very.
So I think when we do a motion, and I'm just saying what it could
be, is that the the MF part or the the townhomes would fall. fall under
whatever it is concurrent with, and then the single-family would fall under R-1
or R-2, whichever one it falls under. 2— it could be the same motion
just like that. Townhomes this, single-family that.
Yeah, then whatever parks and open space things.
Is that going to— Marcus, is that okay if they— You're going
to have 4 categories in there. So basically you've You've got the civic,
parks and open space, neighborhood residential 2, neighborhood residential
1. And you've got the roads that are all ag.
As long as it's clear in the motion, like what
is what, then that's fine. It's a little bit convoluted,
but I think we can work with it. We can kind of— so as long
as we are clear that what's public is public,
what's Multifamily. I think they can sort it out after
that. Is that— Brett, the person who asked the question has to make the motion.
Well, we gotta— so public hearing here. I'm looking right now. I'm trying to figure
it out. Was there any other questions before I go to public hearing? Is that—
let's do that while Brett's studying and see if
we can get it right. So it
is 7:50 and we will open the public hearing.
We'll close the public hearing. And no one is here to speak
on this item. Is there anyone here that didn't get a chance to fill anything
out that would like to speak on this item?
Seeing no one, we'll close the public hearing at 7:50.
And then we'll come back and sing a lullaby while
we wait for the— I think Craig— Brett,
I've got one. So I move that the
City Council approve Agenda Item 16A
according to the chart of affected properties.
Yes, exactly. That's— Second.
Because the chart outlines the current zone, the proposed
zone, the current land use, and the proposed land use. It has for each one
of those. Okay, so we have a motion by Councilmember Whitey
and a second Second by Councilmember Wood, and we'll have a chance to talk about
this motion. Is that also— is that motion also
cover the need to change for the future land use map? Yeah, it does.
Yes. Right. I know that everything's in the
chart. I'm saying, does one motion cover the items that
you're saying? Well, you're saying you think we need to do them separately because we
got it. We got to change the future land use map and change the zone.
I'm asking if one motion is both.
But that chart— No, no, he's saying that the zoning
has to be a separate motion from the— A separate one. Well, I'm gonna let—
He's seen the chart twice. When we did the EMP rezones, we did 2 separate
actions. So Marcus, are you good with one motion or do you want 2?
So we noticed it as one agenda item, right?
So, Can I make a recommendation?
So typically that would have one
motion attached to it.
Yeah, I mean, the concern I am having is that
if there's going to be a general plan amendment, that should generally come as a
separate agenda item and with a separate motion. It's in the description of
the item. The description does say proposed general plan future land use
demand. Amendments and rezoning. Yeah, typically we
do that as separate items. I mean, given that it's one item, I think
it's probably okay to just move forward with one motion approving the agenda
item. In the future, it would be better to do 2 separate
agenda items. Okay, that's why I was asking the question. So is
there any— yeah, I'm gonna— I want to make a suggestion, and I know there's
a motion on the table, Mayor, but I think that a substitute I would like
to ask you to consider a substitute motion. And the motion that I would— that
I would put forward would be to approve the
general plan amendment according to the chart of affected properties
for this item and to approve the zoning in accordance
with the proposed rezoning map for each of the properties.
That's— so moved. I'm good with that. I'll amend my second.
You good? Stephanie?
It's recorded.
Okay. Oh boy. All right. Any questions
on where we're at? Motion's good? Councilmember Whitey made the motion.
I think that's important. He made the motion and council members— Okay. For the
record, Councilmember Whiting made the amended motion and Councilmember Wood
continued to second. And we will start the vote with Councilmember Wood.
Yes. Councilmember Hewish. Yes. Councilmember Clark. Yes.
Councilmember Wrobel-Wright. Are you sure you want me to weigh in? Yes.
Councilmember Whiting. Yes. Okay. Thank you.
Second? Yeah, she did.
Next item. is an ordinance of Eagle Mountain City, Utah,
amending the master plan known as the Transportation Master
Plan, the TMP, and the Impact Fee Facilities Plan.
I know David Salazar has done a lot of work on this, and we'll turn
it to you. Thanks, Mayor, council members.
We're glad to be here. So the purpose of today's
item is that we are bringing the Transportation Master Plan back in the IFP.
Back for review. We're going to try and do these on a year and
a half to 2-year basis. The last year was particularly busy.
That's why we're coming back with some pretty big changes. We didn't want to wait
another year and a half, 2 years to capture.
So some of the summary will be updating some of the current transportation priorities
and plans, updated roadway names,
classifications, revised roadway cross-sections.
We did update the modeling as well. As well as the current costs
and contributions throughout, so we can get a more accurate transportation impact fee.
Excuse me. So I sent you guys an updated
list, kind of a summary of the updates we made, the major updates
that's in your packet. We're going to go through each one of them,
and then I did throw in a couple slides throughout. We can also go through
some topics as well. And focus on some key projects. So the
first main update we did was update the priority project list. In the past project
list, we had the old Mid Valley Road in there as number one.
We we were very successful, and now that's a UDOT facility, so we no longer
need that as our number one priority because we have succeeded. Now we are still
pushing that as much as we can as a city to get that moved up
in the RTP, as well as MAG funding. So that's
something we are actively working on. MAG is currently going through the RTP prioritization process
now, and we've been— I was on the working group,
Mayor and I both were. And so we are heavily giving input on
how they are prioritizing projects because we are trying to let
them know, hey, growth is a huge component for us. It is huge, and it's
been overlooked in western Utah County. And so they— I feel
like they're finally hearing us now, and they're understanding the growth that we have and
the needs and the demands that we have in our area. So that's
a huge one. The other major change to this was we added the Silver Lake
projects, were pulled up the list, and those are the 2—
that's line item number 4. Those are connections to
Saratoga Springs, and those have been on our transportation
master plan since before I was here. But with the new
high school coming online in fall of 2024, We are pulling those up on the
priority list, and so I want to talk a little bit about those connections before
we go on to the next item. So we did a study with
Hales Engineering, and they came back with the intersection at Golden
Eagle and Silver Lake Parkway warranting a traffic signal for the movements that
occurred in that intersection. Their recommendations including removing the roundabout
and adding a traffic signal there, moving all the crossing to.
To the controlled intersection. Currently right now, the north crossing is at
Golden Medal, further to the north, and the recommendation would be to pull everything down
to the intersection with crossing guards.
And then also, they're looking at the east leg of the intersection to realign
it to a more conventional intersection. Currently, that leg is narrow
and skewed, and that can create visibility issues when aligning with intersections,
as well as limitations in site visibility.
So here's 2 photos I have of that intersection.
This is looking eastward. The photo on the left is current conditions,
and the one on the right is AI-generated what those improvements would look like.
So the, the concerns that were brought up last week from Councilmember Wood was
we'd be pushing traffic closer to pedestrians, and it's a very valid concern. And that's
why I wanted to bring this up to you guys so you could have a
chance to understand the intentions of this project. So the,
the dimension of the edge of pavement to trail would be maintained.
We would be realigning that trail in that
right-of-way. The parking lot would stay as is, and we would take
out some of the area in between the edge of trail and the parking lot.
Also, there'd be a— with the wider pavement, we'd now go to a 36-foot
wide width, so we'd have room for a shoulder.
As well, which— and potential on-street parking, which would
actually push traffic further away from the trail. This, again, this 90-degree
alignment provides better visibility for turning movements and pedestrians.
So the other intersection was a little further north at Silver Lake,
Campbell, and Woodhaven. While this intersection was
not a full warrant based on the turning movements, staff and the
consultant did identify concerns from pedestrian crossings, with the recommendations to
improve this intersection. This would also have a traffic signal,
um, and then Silver Lake Parkway would be realigned to tee and terminate
into Woodhaven. Woodhaven would then continue north and south,
and then the southern portion would be Woodhaven going forward.
Um, Campbell Circle, as, as Brett is well— Councilmember
Wright is well aware of, Campbell Circle would be limited
limited access with a crash gate for fire requirements, and Campbell Circuit would have to
access Silver Lake Parkway from the west a few hundred feet with their other access.
And again, this would help with the pedestrian crossings in the area.
Excuse me.
Update number 2 is Lake Mountain Corridor. So this is a screenshot from
our future classification map. It's nice seeing the 2 big blue lines on there.
So we now have 2 major UDOT facilities coming to our region. Cedar Valley
Highway, which peels off of SR 73 in the north
and south direction, and that east and west is Lakemound Corridor, which is currently
called Mid-Valley Road. Now this is going to be a UDOT facility.
UDOT currently has a Mid-Valley Road in Tooele County,
and so we needed a new name. They originally assigned us the name Crown Ridge
Crest, I think it was, and not Nobody liked that name, so council
gave us some good direction on what to name it, right?
They gave some good direction, and MAG and UDOT are both on board.
That name is on the RTP right now, and it's been identified. So that is
the new name of that road. We are working on getting new signage
for Mid Valley and working with Frontier Middle School, the seminary
building, and then the fire station. I forget what UAF station is over there.
Getting those folks readdressed. Once we get the new signs ordered,
we will get them readdressed accordingly.
Update number 3 was just catching typos throughout the project. We found some inconsistencies,
some old references. This was an old document that had been
kind of updated throughout the years. Our next major update,
we're going to start from scratch. We're going to have an all-new document. We've seen
other cities' TMPs, and they're a lot shorter and a lot So we're going to
go to something a little bit different going forward, kind of start from scratch.
So don't threaten us with a good time, David. You don't want
to read 200 pages? You know, come on. It's a good document, but I told
Vince it reads like a book report, so it's, it's tough to follow sometimes.
So we want something that, you know, our residents can follow well,
development, it's easy to follow to look for the information that you need.
Update number 4, we updated the freeway and expressway criteria
in the functional classification. Before, so that first column,
we had the spacing of the traffic movement at 4 miles and it was
high speed only. With the addition of Lake Mountain Corridor,
we needed to lower that in the development regions because
we know Lake Mountain Corridor is going to go through city center and
then some residential up in the mountains as well. But the majority of that is
going to be, you know, we're prioritizing as a high-speed connector, but we
still have to cover the areas that are not. And again,
our goal for this is going to be a limited access, you know,
high-functioning road, but still within some development we will have some connections.
Update number 5 is the roadway cross-sections.
Our old cross-sections had, you know, those beautiful raised landscape medians throughout
on the major collector, minor arterial, and the major arterial.
The new sections have removed those landscaped medians
to improve U-turn flexibility, to remove the hazards
we've seen from accidents from maintenance vehicles working
in the travel lanes. It also reduces blind spots at intersections
and provides additional capacity for turning lanes.
And I spoke with our arborist. Even though we're going to be removing some of
these landscape We are going to be working on kind of beautifying our park strips
and adding more greenage because we want to maintain that Eagle Mountain feel and
not turn this into a concrete jungle.
So that's a key priority we're working on, especially along Pony Express and
Ranches. Those are our 2 areas we don't want to lose that green. I'm from
the Midwest, so I like green. So the sage is okay, but I like the
green personally. So here's an image.
Of those 3 sections, the top one didn't change. We just redid it
with great help from our communications department. So we
have added a turning— center turning lane in the major collector,
the minor arterial, and the major arterial.
We've also added a new roadway classification, the principal arterial.
And this is to help with some of the confusion, because before we had 2
major arterials. One was a five-lane, one was a seven-lane. And looking at the map,
it could be confusing to understand which is what right-of-way, what's the lane configuration.
So we took away the old park strip, a parkway cross-section,
which was a four-lane road with large landscape
medians and no shoulders. This will be a seven-lane arterial,
and it has two right-of-ways: 176 for new developments,
and then the 206 is for the existing. Existing preserved right-of-way along Pony
Express and Ranches Parkway.
And it makes it again just easier when we go to the overall map.
You'll see the, the line work is just easier to follow. You know, it works
better for planning and development.
So now we're going to talk a little bit about Ranches Parkway, as this was
a very important project. It's one of our, it's one of our busiest corridors
in the whole city, as we know. So Ranches
Parkway is 4 lanes with a very large 37-foot median in
the middle. We've had major traffic congestion along the way.
Speeding is an issue. Enforcement is limited because
of the limited turn— U-turn movements throughout the corridor.
There's no protected pedestrian crossings from Pony
Express to SR 73— well, excuse me, until you hit Stonebridge just
before the Maverick. We've also had multiple crashes in this corridor.
And so with this project, we're looking to improve in 2 phases.
So phase 1, we're looking to remove the landscape medians and
add 1 additional travel lane in each direction and a center turn lane.
With this project, we're also looking to add 2 traffic
signals, kind of about third points throughout the corridor, one at
Half Mile and the other at Braxton, and then limit the other access.
On the parkway, and those accesses will either be ride-in ride-outs
or three-quarter. And for our residents, a three-quarter is a ride-in ride-out
or left-in because left-outs are your longest turning movements and often are
the most hazardous and time-consuming. Where a left-in, you face traffic and
you often have momentum to make your turn in. The other accesses can
reach those traffic signals and still make their protected left-outs.
Again, we're going to beautify the park strips and
add more trees and shrubs throughout. And with this, we're going to improve the intersection
at Pony Express and Ranches. As you know, that intersection is
probably one of our worst intersections in the city. We're looking to add
dual left turn lanes heading east to north,
and then we're going to add dual right lanes south to west.
And then every leg will have a dedicated right turn lane. Turn lane as we
overall widen the intersection. So the other challenge of Pony Express
and Ranches is that when you need to slow down and make a turn,
there's no turn lane. So you now are impeding all your traffic who's already
congested anyway. So we will be having, you know, dedicated turn pockets for all those
movements. And this summer we are doing construction on
the north end of that project at 73 and Ranches.
We're widening that to 6 lanes, so we'll have 2 left turn lanes,
2 throughs and 2 rights. And then we're adding a signal at Campus
Drive, a high tee, so vehicles can exit that safely.
That's Phase 1. Phase 2 is going to come
5 to 15 years later. We're not quite sure on that timing yet, but that
will come when the new sewer trunk line is needed. From this graphic here,
you can see it's under the shoulder. I don't have a laser pointer,
but it's, it's under the, the far Right shoulder.
And so for that Phase 2, we'll kick out the curb about 10 feet to
provide a shoulder for emergency vehicles being pulled over, maintenance, or other
emergencies. And then we'll install that new sewer trunk line out there.
And then there's parts of the trail that run up against the curb, so we'll
adjust those back so the curb— the trail is not right up on the curb
and there's still park strip in between, so the pedestrians have a buffer there.
And this also improves safety because Adding a shoulder is critical for vehicles
who are not paying attention to the road, and this way they don't get ejected
off the road and drive into the park strip. So that's another safety feature we're
adding. So Phase 1, I took to MAG earlier
this year for the 2016 TIP selection,
and we competed with other cities for funding,
and we made it through the concept and the idea
cycle. And we were shortlisted 4th out of the cities for
funding. This funding selection is scheduled to be
awarded next Thursday at the MPO board meeting.
It's already gone through TAC and been recommended.
And so if that's the case, this project will be a funded project through MAG
in '29-'30. Funds will be available. And so
the current funds are $11.8 million with future
funds inflated. 13.8. And that is the largest
project that the city will be awarded by MAG to date.
So some of the concerns we had from the residents who live in the
ranches was, hey, can we— you know, not going to the meetings, you know,
can we maybe put our efforts and look at working on Airport
Road? Is that an option? Will that be able to kind of save the ranches
as it is or prolong it as long as we can? And so we looked
at that as we're updating our modeling. This is the latest model of the existing
level of service, and we have the Airport Road in there with 2
lanes. Currently, Ranches Parkway is at 29,100,
which is just shy of failing at 31,400.
Before, it was failing at 33,300. So Airport did
save us a little bit, but if we look at the future, It does fail
pretty quickly, actually. And we do know at the intersections
it's already failing. So this is a no-build situation.
We leave Airport Road at 2 lanes, Ranches at 4, just to show how bad
it could be. The worst along Ranches is at 39,900,
which is severely failing at that point.
And then the ask from the residents was if
we widen Airport Road first to 5 lanes, What does that do for the ranches?
And we just do the intersection improvements.
Well, if you look at the, uh, the image here, it actually makes it fail
more because we've now essentially relieved that bottleneck
that is the southern connection and allowed more traffic to flow onto
ranches. So if you look
at what we're projecting for a build-out in 2035, Ranches Parkway
at a 7-lane would have additional capacity from the induced demand,
which you get, which is normal. But that puts us at about 45,900.
And that still leaves us with about, with some capacity left over.
A 7-lane maxes out at 50,500.
So still having capacity until we start seeing the Cedar Valley Airport come
on, which will help divert some of this traffic as we approach the
2040-ish, 2045 timeline.
So Spring Run, as we've been seeing development kind of
getting interest and traction in this area, we spent a lot of time with the
folks out there and working back and forth. Their engineers sent through
a few different transportation impact studies, and we have come
up with the, the best layout that we could for the region
to service as a third connection kind of from the city.
Case there's ever issues on 73. And so this would hopefully
get us additional connections to the Wildflower development
there. Um, it's something we're actually working with Saratoga Springs as
this area develops. It's, it's going to go from
west to east, as we know, just as the development is occurring and as they're
mining out there. But that's something we're actively looking at, and we want to stay
ahead of it so we can kind of not design things after the fact.
We're trying to get ahead of things in the city and build for the future.
So with these maps and new layouts, we went and ran new modeling just so
we could understand the better the traffic flow. This helps us understand the prioritization
of projects at the staff level and what's needed in the future at 2035,
in the near future, or at build-out or at 2050.
And then from that, that helps us update the project list as well.
Then we updated the future functional— sorry, the functional classification
map. This is that line work I was talking about that helps us kind of
easier to determine which roadway is what.
And there is an addendum I do need to add into motion if we can,
if, if it gets to that point. There was a line that was dropped
off at East 1000 North. I've got a better image of that I will show
later if we can include that. There was a line that didn't index
All the way, so I will show that in a little bit. We then went
up and updated the project cost. As we went through
the project, we found that our consultant had a lot of money kind of
delineated to MAG and some developers. And while that's great,
and while we would love to have more money from them, like we can't always
count on these things because we know the MAG cycling is every two years,
and there's no guarantee of funds. And so, as a city, we have to plan
for these things and. Kind of a worst-case scenario and see how can we fund
these roads effectively. And we're always trying to look for ways to partner and
work with MAG and other entities, but at the end of the day, we have
to make sure we're capturing cost accurately so we can have an accurate
transportation impact fee.
So that's kind of the overall effects of the update, what we were going through,
trying to be consistent to get things up to date as best
as we could as a snapshot. You know, this is like trying to hit a
moving target. It's always updating every day. There's always something new going on. But at
one point we have to just say this is it. We have to present to
you our plan in its current form to hopefully get it approved and
then, you know, keep working on things in the future.
David, just for clarification for me, you said that we needed
to add East 1000 North. Yeah, so it's
in the recommendation. OK, that's what I want on the recommendation. So staff recommends
City Council, you know, adopt this with this caveat, adding this line.
There's some major development going down south kind of next to the Meta,
and this road right here, it's, it's not really a prescriptive road. It's just
used as a utility access road kind of under the power corridor. But we would
love to see that as the collector kind of connecting Pony Express and our East
Expressway. Agreed. And then, and then I have 2 more questions, Mayor, if I may.
As far as the road sections that are contained in the TMP,
what I'm really wondering is, do we need to update those if we should we
choose to adopt this? Do we need to update those in our other section of
code? I believe we probably will want to so that they're so
they match. We have road classifications
as part of I don't know if it's sixteen or seventeen. It's in one of
those code sections. I just. I'll speak into the mic. I know nobody
can hear me. I'm getting some shakes from the back. I'm just wondering
if we need to bring back a different section of code that identifies the road
sections. We're going to need to update that if we go with this,
right? Well, so we're not changing any widths. We're just, we're just removing
the medians. So I don't know if that's going to affect code because we're not
changing the described— Yeah, but they're contained in the code section that talks about road
classification. So I just think we're going to want them to match. Okay,
we'll do that then. And then, uh, let's see,
and did we contact or have any interaction with the Wildlife Alliance?
Did they get a chance to review the conflict map? That's the last
page in this TMP. We didn't update that at all from
this latest go-round. So, so it didn't change? It didn't change. That's what I wanted
to know. Thank you. One question for me with
the Lake Mountain Corridor. In our combined meeting that we They mentioned
that UDOT would not be building the road.
Do you want to just talk to that point? It made
it feel like they're going to take it over after we build it, kind of
a scenario. So I don't have a great answer for that.
I mean, because I've heard conflicting information on that, to be perfectly honest.
I've heard they are, and I've read the code myself, and that is exactly
how it's written. But I think there's other things at play. On how that's going
to go, I think this is this kind of road adoption is unique. I don't
think it's ever been written in this way before. So I suspect this is kind
of the first step to them fully taking it over. But again, I don't have
specifics on that. I know that's something we're working with our lobbyist as well,
and Stephanie and some of the other folks to
get some clarification so that that language is clear. So okay,
just a little insight. That was one of the things that I did in.
I saw like a couple weeks ago, I was talking with Mike Schultz,
and I think the key— and I was working with Stephanie on this as well—
it's more about getting it on the funding,
which is a long ways away. And once it's funded, even if we build it,
then they pay for it. It's— I think it's
more whether or not it's an internal project for them to build themselves or subcontract
it. And I think if we pre-build it, If they
fund it to a 2032, 2033 type programming,
then we'd likely move that forward by funding it or building it with
a subcontractor and then getting reimbursed just like we do with MAG. So something of
that nature is what we're working on, or at least proposing. So I think
it's a combination of both, right? Yeah.
So any other questions? Go ahead. Great presentation.
Yeah, thank you, David. That's really helpful. It's a long document,
222 pages, so if you can shorten that up a few,
that would be helpful. Gladly. So this is just more of a question on
the flexibility as we kind of move forward.
And really, Ranches Parkway sticks out in my mind because I was
at that same meeting, and I agree, it probably needs to be widened out 3
lanes on both sides. Is there any flexibility in design where you
have the ability to do U-turns, you can narrow the median? I think the medians
right now are— they're built up way too high, they're way too wide,
they don't get watered, they look terrible. I don't know how many trees we have
in there. We could probably relocate or rehome a bunch of those trees, but I'm
curious if there's any flexibility in design with what we're voting on tonight
to retain some median To retain the character
when you enter our city versus turning into the city past
the Maverick and just seeing, you know, a big open asphalt field, 'cause it's
a pretty straight shot. So my question to you is, is there flexibility
in the design? Are we adopting this kind of as is? So I think,
I mean, we could look at that. Staff is recommending to get away with
the medians from a few reasons. You know, we talked about the
U-turns and things like that, but there's also other questions, concerns I didn't bring up,
like water intrusion. When you have these medians, you know, you're watering
that area, the subgrade becomes soft. Ranches and Pony
have had more maintenance than a typical road section because that water percolates through
and it affects the subgrade to the adjacent roadway. And so it eventually,
it affects the crown of your road. There's other factors as well versus
kind of capping off and having a proper— crown profile
of the road, if you will. And so I think the consensus has been just
to get away from that. The maintenance has been a huge issue. There have been
accidents of workers being hit, residents being hit as
well from this. And so I feel like we've outgrown that
as a city. I know I haven't been here, my tenure hasn't been that long,
but with the volume of traffic we have, I just think it's— I wish
we could keep them, but I don't think it services the city. And that's why
we're trying to look to beautify the landscapes in other things. We have 40
to 60 feet of landscape in Ranches Parkway, and so there's a lot of things
to work with. And I'm working with our arborist to see how we can really
spruce that, kind of bang that entrance up really well as you come down.
Yeah, I mean, I, I— when you turn into UVU,
I'll use that as an example, coming off the freeway, I mean, there's a nice
median. It just makes— I think medians make it interesting,
if you know what I mean. When you're driving down a road, it breaks up
Just the monotony of just a flat asphalt surface, so that that's just
one one thing to consider. And I'm not saying that we need to have grass;
that's probably terrible to have out there. The way that we're watering the asphalt doesn't
make any sense, but some basic drip lines for trees.
I think for me as a resident, I it there's character at that part
of our city, and I just it like makes me kind of sad just to
see that completely go away. Isn't the high T— you're talking about just
a barrier at all? High T, I'm good. I'm like 80%
of the way there on that specific road. High T's, I'm good. Intersections, all of
that probably needs to happen, even the widening of the lanes. Well, I'm saying the
high T is the— there's a median, like you wouldn't be able to go across
campus in the Maverick. There is a barrier. It's not a landscape.
Right, but this— right, the high T, it's gotta go on
both ends. Completely. I'm talking about where there's stretches
of long span of road, just having something where you're
not turning, it's just a span of road, keeping something in there to keep
the road kind of interesting.
In terms— in other words, because there's those some longer stretches where someone
might not need the middle lane to do something, can you keep some kind of
decorative feature? Some trees, shrubs, with some
rocks in there, some desert. I don't know. Just,
it's a question if we could retool that or redesign that a little bit.
Turn your mic on, Dave. Thanks, guys. Even if we're not watering it, like,
someone still has to go in and maintain that and clean that. I mean,
so there is a safety component of that, especially if we're adding more
lanes and more traffic. So I know from— if Zach were here,
I know he'd be pulling on his beard right now as well. I get
it. I totally get it. I'm here to represent the residents
that live in that area, and I think it's worth
at least considering the design and retaining some features in
the middle there. So I'm going to throw out a quick question just
to be sure before we spend time maybe doing that. Does council agree with that?
I'm not sure. that there's a— I'll probably tell you, Mayor, that I'm, I'm not
favorable to that. I mean, and look, I, I understand the sentiment,
um, Councilmember Hewish. For you, it's about the aesthetics and the way it feels.
And I know Councilmember Wood has spoken about how that felt to him when he
first came into the city. So I think that there's, there's a real impact
there. But as, as I look at that and try to balance
the maintenance aspect of it, the safety aspect of it for
our employees who have to take care of it, the water in there and the
additional road damage. I think that the suggestion,
and this is at least what I think David was alluding to, is improving
those sidescapes is what I'm going to call them, so the edges of the road,
so that they take on that type of character. I think that's
a good compromise. But if we're going
to remove the medians, we're going to remove the medians. And every place that they've
come out, They've come out, and we've while I've been
here, we've made some improvements. And it is for me, it's too little
too late. It's like when we did the left turn pocket on Pony
Express Parkway, where you turn left onto ranches. We extended that
100 feet, and it was worthless because by the time that it was done,
it was still backing up into the travel lane. I just think that we have
a volume of traffic that we have to get in and. Out of the city,
and that's a major thoroughfare for our city. And I know some of the residents
there said, well, tell everybody in City Center to take Airport Road. We don't want
them coming down Ranches. Well, I don't, I don't adopt that philosophy. I think
citizens in the City Center ought to have the choice of where they want
to exit the city, including Lake Mountain Corridor. So for,
for me, I just, I, I think that, I think we're holding
on to something that belongs in a smaller in a smaller road network.
So I'll— I'm going to hit somewhere in the middle on
this one. I agree with what you're saying, Brett. I think that it—
that road needs to be without any barriers in the middle of it. I think
we've seen enough accidents. Uh, it is an absolute blind spot coming out
of any of those roads. However, I don't
think we should go small when we do the landscaping on the side
It— we're well known for that entrance into the city, and it should
still present itself the same way when we do the sidescapes on
the side. It should be incredibly beautiful the way that it is right now,
in a way that can be presented on the side. So when we're looking at
that, let's, let's put our best foot forward, uh, and make that
area just as striking as it has always been, uh, for our city.
It ought to look like a golf of course, Councilmember Wood, and, and sincerely,
and it ought to have the impact of protecting
those residents from that major roadway, from some of the noise,
the lights, and some of those other impacts. I, I think that's where we can
make a difference for the residents. And can I show a quick example? So this
is Stonebridge, and so this is one great example because we have these great,
you know, trees here in the middle, then we have this bare patch over here.
And so we're looking at bringing in Trees, you know, landscaping this
up, making it look really good. So we're kind of moving the green over,
and any trees we can't relocate, we're going to reuse as mulch. So nothing's
getting thrown away, everything's going to be repurposed throughout the city. We're going to try
and relocate things, but it doesn't always work.
So— I, I think I,
I get the vision. Our track record,
when I drive through City Center and I look at our True. Or even
on Ranches Parkway now. It just, it just doesn't look good.
And I think if we're going to pull that median out, it's got to look
awesome. And I'm just going to give you that commission to
really impress, to blow us away with the landscaping. I don't
know whose job that is, but our track record throughout the city
has not been great.
As we mentioned previously, I mean, The ranches in the Pony
Corridor, it's been an interesting one because a lot
of the side streets, just like we've talked about in the city center,
we've had a lot of fiber companies come through and they
wreck irrigation systems. And I think our park staff has
made a significant push in trying to get those irrigation systems
operating again. And I feel like there's a little bit of an improvement.
I think where when we take these medians out, we just need to plan Plant
some more trees and shrubberies on the side of the road where it's feasible,
because there's still going to be some narrow pockets that won't fit trees
either. So we just need to lay it out in a way.
But we're hoping that we're getting towards the
end of these fiber companies destroying stuff when they come through multiple times
every year, and it makes it hard to maintain.
And I I couldn't agree more with. the medians, they,
they need to come out. I, I think about Pioneer
Crossing and they put the medians in there and how long did that last?
And I just feel like if we just do a scale back, we're not
going to meet the mark. I think we need to like meet
the mark with it and let's attempt to do the sides and get
it up to par so that it has that look and that feel that you're
requesting. So I think I just want to Maybe
stamp this one. Let's design it. Let's not dig holes and
put trees in. Like, this needs to have an actual design, a landscaping design,
to be brought to us to, to match what the citizens have
become to expect in that area. And then let's
set that as the standard of how we're going to go down our corridors so
that it's not one area that's getting this, that this is something we're working for
over the next 5 and 10 years so that our corridors are
something that is reflective of how we feel about our city.
Yeah, I was actually going to exactly recommend that thing. Get a landscape
architect and let's do it right and design that,
and then we can see what Pony could look like as well. And we got
to put the funds into these areas. We just have to. And I think if
we can show the residents that live in that area, hey, this is what it
will become, they may say, we, we love this. It's gonna be
safer, it's gonna be better, but it's also going to look more beautiful for them
because that The trail is just going to go up right along where their homes
are. I love that idea, but I think we got to put the money into
it and actually make it real. It's the entrance, one of the entrances to the
city. It's the first impression, so we got to make it great.
100%. We absolutely plan on doing that. And on Pony Express,
what we're looking to do is later this year or even next fiscal year,
we're looking to do a study on Pony Express to see what that looks
like, what it looks like removing the medians, The landscape component,
and something that was brought up in the last council or two councils ago was
the monuments. Ranches and
Pony Express have a lot of monuments, and that's been a big character of our
city. We don't want to get rid of that. And when we widen, they're going
to have to go where they are for the turn movements and the width.
And so part of this project and the study on Pony Express is to look
at where's the best place we can put these new monuments in so we can
maintain that feel. for the city, but still have our turning movements and our travel
lanes. Is the design what we're talking
about built into that $11.4 million? Yes. With MAG?
Yep. So it's $11.4 million. Golf course level design? Yep. Okay, David.
It's a full design. It's a lot of contingency because we
know MAG loves contingency. It's also money for construction and
management. We usually— we handle management ourselves. throughout construction.
This is a big enough project, we're going to hire out someone to help us
with construction inspection management because it's a big project. And, you know, we'll have
other things going on as well. So all those have been budgeted.
I think it's important to mention, I know there's a lot of attention
on the City Council right now because we're looking at different funding options
for us as a city. And I think if somebody were to tune in,
they'd be like, they want to spend their money on a golf
Of course, landscaping and all of those things. And I think it's important to help
people understand that one, this will be money that we get from
the state through MEG. So it's not like we're wasting taxpayer
dollars by doing something. And two, this has a big impact
on property values and different things like that. And ultimately, we won't do it if
we don't have the funds to back it up. And I think normally we
wouldn't have to stop and say that, but I want residents to understand that we're
not just like on a spending spree, that this is a part of a long
process of finding the funding to go toward it. So that's
it. So just
ask clarifying questions again. So Phase 1 of Ranches Parkway
would begin when approximately? And then, and then
Phase 1 does not include widening, right? So, so there's nothing happening
on the widening just yet on Phase 1? Correct. So for Phase
1, the project, if everything goes smoothly, next week,
next Thursday, we, we'll be awarded this project. Funding will be secured with the MPO
meeting. Then we would then work with, um, we have budgeted for fiscal
year '27 to kind of cash flow this project because we know the road's already
going to fail. The intersection's already failing down at the south end.
And what we've done with a lot of MAG projects is the city has cash
funded parts of it and then entered into an interlocal for reimbursement
so we can get these projects done sooner than later than waiting until 2030.
And so this is something, once next week it gets approved,
I'm going to be then drafting an interlocal with Utah County and,
um, UDOT to get this funding in place so we can begin design
hopefully in the next month or two. So, David,
and just to clarify this, when we typically, like Airport Road for instance,
uh, MAG Funded that, we built it, and we're
still waiting on some reimbursement. This Phase 1,
we do these improvements right away even though the funding— is it 2029?
It's, it's '29 through '30. Yes. '30. So, so, but yeah,
we start this project. Yep, right away.
And, and the great thing is, because the city uses this approach, we actually
saved money on this. We did Airport Road. I forget the dollar on Airport Road,
but when we did the roundabout removal at Eagle Mountain Boulevard and Pony Express.
That was a $3.6 million project with, uh, it was MAG
funded, and we saved, I think it was $800,000 we left over.
And they're allowing us to use that to continue some of the widening further south
because we cash funded that. Because from this,
this diagram here, you know, the project was estimated $11.8
million current dollars, and they budget for 2030 funds, which is, you know,
$13.8 million. So So if we can do it early, it's kudos to
us. Like us, Saratoga and Lehigh are some of the few
cities that cash flow and do these early. Most other cities, they're late.
They come back asking for extra money. So like we're ahead of the game and
we're going to— that's the way we can save our residents money and use those
funds to better purpose. So we've
spent a lot of time on specifically ranches, but it's the entire TMP that we're
looking at here. I just wanted to make sure that especially Councilmember Hewish is comfortable
with— at least I heard 2 opinions on that removal of the roundabout or
medians. Are you comfortable if we move on without?
Yeah, we can move forward. Okay. I know you wanted to go with
some design elements and I didn't want to direct staff to do that if there
wasn't an appetite. So I'm talking about the median specifically.
Isn't that part of the— No, so Councilmember Herwish was saying he wanted to
leave some of the median, and Councilmember Wright said he wanted to take them out.
So I'm saying it's 1-1 right now. I don't know. I think we're going to
take them out, but then we're going to— okay, then we're going to make a
motion at some point, like later in the meeting, that we'll hire a landscape architect
and we'll do a corridor landscape plan. That's already in
the funding. Yeah, so I don't think we need to make a motion because that's
in the budget. So when we put together that proposal for MAG, we have all
that in the estimate. We're going to want to review that plan too.
Like, where you can say, hey, look, here's what the landscaping is going to look
like. I think we'd want to see that before you move forward. And we will
absolutely bring that to you guys. Absolutely. I mean, that design will take months.
It will. It's not a quick process.
And if there's opportunity to relocate those trees— I don't—
I'm not a tree hugger, but there's a lot of trees in there. So we
got to relocate them somewhere if if that's possible, and we always try to.
It's not always feasible when they come out. If not, we reuse all the
trees. We mulch it, and we use it throughout the city, so nothing gets wasted
or thrown away. Okay, so was there any other questions on the
TMP as a whole aside from ranches? Go ahead. Yeah, I had a question.
So the last page as well, page 222.
So you said that that one was not updated. There are some roads in
there. that are not reflected in some of the other pages.
So do we need to make— do we need to worry about that? For instance,
I'm looking at one in specific, and that is it's showing a
road connecting to Canyon Wash, which we had turned to the west
to connect to Airport Road. So page 222, the last page.
So that's using a map that has— so Canyon Wash is showing a
road to connect to. Yeah. That, that was just an old background that I guess
got turned on. So if you want to make your motion, we can make sure
to delete that connection. Thank you for catching that. Yeah, there's no plans to
make that connection. That was deleted off a year ago.
Yeah,
yeah, because we cut on all the other maps, but on the wildlife one,
I guess it's still showing. So thank you for pointing that out. Okay,
if there's no other question right now, this is a public hearing. We good to
move forward? Yeah. All right, we'll go ahead and open the public hearing at 8:35.
And I think there's people to speak on this one. They listened to a
lot of discussion there, so go ahead. Quinn Lindy.
We're glad your school's still standing and not burned down. Thank you, I appreciate
that. Um, Mayor and Council,
my name is Quinn Lindy. I am the principal of the new high school that
was opening in Saratoga Springs. First and foremost, what you should know,
Mayor, is, you know, I've done my fair share of Big
Mac challenges, hot wing challenges, Chick-fil-A.
I had 40 chicken nuggets in 3 minutes.
You always say no when the students asked you to do stupid things like
that. So just on the record, say no next time. You'll be better off for
it. Thank you. Thank you for it. I prepared something more
formal, and I don't know if 3 minutes is going to be enough time.
And so I'm going to keep my comments short. Most importantly,
this road that we talked about in our TMP plan to connect
Golden Eagle down through the new high school into Saratoga
Springs, this road will provide important traffic support and additional access for
high school students. As enrollment continues to increase, having multiple routes
into and out of our new high school in our community will become increasingly important.
A direct connection here will provide our families and students with more options for reaching
school and other community destinations. It will help distribute
traffic rather than concentrating it on a limited number of existing roads. Why I say
this is I have opened a new school, I have rebuilt a school of
20— for 2,800 students at Hillcrest High School, and I've currently, when I look left
my last job building a $65 million extension onto Murray High
School. I have been in my fair share of high
schools. I will submit to the record a data analysis
that I put together of the last 20 high schools that were built in the
state of Utah. Westlake and Cedar Valley are also on that list.
I won't go through that entire thing here, but I will refer you to that
record and where we currently fall in Alpine School District.
With the number of access points into high school? Quite frankly,
not very good. In fact, we are in the
just above average. Schools down in St. George,
schools in Nebo School District are much, much better. Meaning on average,
we are sending about 900 students per access point
compared to our counterparts across the state. If you don't believe me on this,
go read the recent news articles about the $225
million building they built Cypress High School, and the first issue and the first
news article that came out was parents waiting an hour to drop their kids off
at school due to the lack of access points into the community.
When communities are physically connected, it becomes easier for people to interact,
participate, and build relationships. I want to be very— 30 seconds remaining. I want to
be very clear, this is not an Eagle Mountain High School. It will not be
a Saratoga Springs High School. I live in Eagle Mountain and I have since 2013.
and I am an Eagle Mountaineer. This school will represent both of
our communities, and I want you to know that I put my full support behind
our TMP plan to build and connect our roads because one day
our marching band and our programs will march through Silver
Lake and they'll march through Evans Ranch and any other area our district sees fit
in that boundary study. I also want you to know that I will advocate with
the new school district— Your time is up. Thank you. Eagle Mountain in
our new boundary study that will begin in September. Thank you. So any
of those other documents, if you wanna send your full comment, just email it to
Lacey, to recorder@eaglemountain.gov,
and we can attach them to the record and the council can get them up
there. Can I send this to you now?
Next comment. Melissa Powers.
Good evening, Mayor Gray and members of the City Council. My name is
Melissa Powers. I live in Evans Ranch neighborhood, which butts up right against
Silver Lake, so we're all just kind of one big area.
First, I wanted to thank you guys for your time tonight and
for all the work you put into this process. I know it's been a long
road for all of you, and I appreciate the time and thought that's gone into
it. Many of you have seen me up
here already, so I wanted to talk about the Silver Lake
Parkway connection. I wanted to come one last time before
tonight's vote because I wanted to make sure you heard from those of us who
support the transportation master plan and especially the Silver
Lake Parkway connection. The plan before the council is about preparing Eagle Mountain's
transportation network for future growth. I've had Councilman. Thank you,
Mr. Mayor. I've had countless conversations with the residents through Evans Ranch and Silver
Lake and the surrounding communities since all of this started,
and I can confidently tell you there is tremendous amount of
support for this plan. To me, it's become so
much more than just the Silver Lake Parkway connection.
It's about improving Woodhaven, it's about improving
Golden Eagle, and most importantly, it's about connecting
our neighborhoods to the new high school, which is really important to
us residents right there in that area. I truly
believe that these improvements will help connect our community and
give better opportunities to the students and families that are living there.
And I just wanted to know that we are behind that plan. Thank you for
your time. Ben Perez.
Good evening, Mayor and Council. I just wanted to keep my comments brief
about the same support for this master plan change.
I wanted to just share really briefly, my son attended the
ALL program at Silver Lake Elementary last year, and one thing
that he was adamant about was that he did not want us to pick him
up in front of the school. He wanted us to park right
down the street and he wanted to cross on his own and get in the
car. He didn't want to cross with all the other kids crossing across Silver Lake
Parkway. He wanted to come down around the roundabout
and get in the car. We had to park on that side. And we
trusted him at first. We were like, let's try this. And we stayed there for
the duration, but I watched countless kids go through that roundabout and nearly get
hit. Because of that? because it's a roundabout, right? There's no—
there's nothing stopping unless you're on the south side of that roundabout
to let kids cross. So seeing that there's a possibility
of that traffic light getting put in there really makes me happy just
because kids' safety is massive. Sure, it will connect to the high
school and it will open up the opportunity there for our neighborhood, but for kids
to have another possibility, 'cause I can't tell you how many of those kids after
school are walking by themselves home. Yeah. they need
some kind of traffic control to stop those cars and let
them cross. So I'm already excited about what's been happening on Golden Eagle
Road with some of the lines that have been painted. I spoke to David earlier
tonight, so I see some positive changes, but I just wanna call
it out that at the end of the day, while we all want more connections
and it feels like we're all a day late and a dollar short trying to
get more ways to get through the city, this really matters most
because of the kids, the kids that their, their parents aren't home yet
and they got to walk home alone. Um, we got to make sure they get
home safely, and this just feels like a really positive direction. So thank
Okay, that's all that we have turned in. Is there anyone else here that came
to speak on this item? Seeing no one,
it is 8:43, and we'll close the public hearing, bring it back to council for
Any further discussion or a motion? Can I ask one more question on— David,
sorry, I was going to ask you this earlier and I got sidetracked. On Airport
Road, it— will that be a principal arterial
street? Is that the plan?
I think my understanding was that would always be— That's correct. That'll be a principal
arterial at 176. And is that a change from the prior plan? Nope.
No, the naming has changed. It was always a 176. It was just confusing on
what the name was, and so we just wanted to rename it so it was
clear what it was.
Mayor, I just— I would just want to ask
the principal of the new high school just to do me a favor and just
share that data with ASD and share it with our— I mean, our Lake Mountain
School District representative is here. I think it's really important because we press
from this side of the dais against— with the school district. But the reality of
it is, is we have little ability to impact how many connections they make into
their school sites. The state law doesn't allow us to do that.
So the fact that we're deficient really rests with our
school districts and with the state legislature. And we have— we've
counseled with our state counterparts and encouraged them to bring forward some code
changes that would allow cities to help regulate that. So anything you can do to
help us there, you'll be— we'll be fighting on the same team. So that,
that, that's a plea that I'm going to make with you. That's, that's an interesting
statistic, and I look forward to seeing it. 900 cars per connection, and perhaps
we can challenge our Lake Mountain School District representative to take that back
and counsel together with, with her counterparts and see if we can't set
a standard that's better than that. That's the first
thing, and Beyond that, I, I'm, I'm good
to go when the council— and if the council's ready to go. I want to
add on to that. Uh,
Melissa is not going to hear anything different than what she's heard me say before,
but I'm going to remind all of the Lake Mountain board
members, one of the things that you all promised is better collaboration with
the city councils before you buy the land. And I
think that I want to re-highlight because it is so important to sit down
and work out these details before you've spent the money.
We had no say whatsoever in that purchase of that high school.
It was in the wrong place for every reason. And now
all of us are scrambling trying to create safe routes for
walking, safe routes for driving. That, that's not the way to do
things, and we've made that mistake over and over and over in this
this area. We need your support from a staff member. We need— Melissa, if you
want— excuse me, Mrs. Powers, what was your first name? It's Melissa.
Melissa Powers. We need our residents to put that kind of pressure back on
the school district to remind them the importance of that collaboration
so we're not putting schools in places that it's impossible to create
safe routes. It is very difficult after the fact
to try to come and mitigate things, especially especially when we have David in here
showing us that we're gonna do these large corridors to be able
to move traffic through, and then the school district comes and puts a school there.
And now we have to make a decision. Which one's more important?
Safe routes or traffic?
And I would just encourage that to be at the very forefront of those decisions
as you guys are making those, to remember we need to sit and talk before
we spend money. Thanks. Thank you.
No other comment. I think Councilmember Wright is ready to make a motion.
Okay, so quick comment to Councilmember Wood's
comment. I spoke with Julie King last Thursday, and we're actually in the process
of getting a meeting, a regular recurring meeting schedule, so I can kind of get
ahead of these things, understand where are these schools coming, what can we do as
we're working with the planning as well. Let's get ahead of this. So I'm— we're
100% on board with that.
All right, Mayor, if you'll entertain a motion.
Let me get— now I'm stuck in the wrong spot. Let me go back a
page. I left a recommendation up for you too. And also just
to remember— Go ahead. Just remember page 222, the— yeah.
Yeah, I've got that. So my
motion is this.
Okay, well then this is easy then. I move that the Eagle Mountain
City Council— excuse me.
Golly, I'm still lost. I'll do it. No, I want to
do it. Where am I? Here we go.
I'm there. Took me a minute, but I'm old and I'm slow, but I'll get
there. I, I moved that the Eagle Mountain City Council adopt
an ordinance amending the master transportation plan
known as the Transportation Master Plan, TMP,
and Impact Fees Facility Plan with
staff recommendations that are on the screen currently.
Second. OK, we have
a motion by Councilmember Wright and a second by Councilmember Wood. Is there any questions
on the motion? Clear.
And we'll start a vote with Councilmember Hewish.
Yes. Councilmember Clark. Yes. Councilmember Wright. Yes.
Councilmember Whiting. Yes. Councilmember Wood. Yes. Okay, that motion carries.
All right, um, we went through the legislative priority list
earlier. Uh, I think John went home, so is there any other things that you
guys need to So you're suggesting we
do not need to make a specific motion regarding the design
of the landscape architect corridor landscape plan?
Or we can require them to bring it back to us. Yeah, it's going to
come back when they build it. Okay, should we make them— should we make a
motion to require them to bring that back? Well, I think the direction's clear
that they'll bring it back, so. Okay, if they don't, Jared, Mayor Gray, we got
this recorded. Yeah, that's right. If they don't, they did it without
telling me, but it'll come back. So we'll dang sure have that
back as we design that. And that's probably at least a couple years out,
right? Because we're talking about phase— that's
phase— not phase 1, that's at least phase 2. So then
if there's no other priorities on that,
we can move to item 18 as far as liaison
and councilmember reports. I just want
to remind everyone that UTA, even though they're not giving us
our bus route, is going to be doing on-demand
for our community. And they're having an open house
tomorrow night at 3688 Campus Drive.
And UTA representatives, Utah County
Commissioner Skyler Beltran, will be there.
What's cool about it is you can order, uh,
basically like an Uber or a Lyft, but it's through UTA,
and the price for it is $2.50. And I
can imagine a lot of kids who have to get to M-TEC or from
one high school to the next using this. So please encourage
people in your life that could benefit from this to come, or just come
so that you can share information with other people, because We want this to be
wildly successful so I can say to UTA,
I told you so, and then get us more routes. So thank you.
Okay. I know there's no reports from Councilmember Wright. Did you have the
Youth Council? We saw them all tonight. Is there anything else? No. Party's tomorrow.
That's right. 2:00 tomorrow at the Cory Ride, right?
And anything there? Thank you. On what?
Liaison reports. Oh, just the Community Services Board?
Any of them. Yes. We met, had a great meeting. We're working on becoming
a— was it healthy city in Utah?
So we're excited to kind of push that across the goal line and prioritizing
some RAP tax projects.
Perfect. And we heard a lot about MAG tonight.
Any reports that I'd have, I think you guys have heard Also,
I went to the UFA board meeting last week.
Everything's moving forward there just like we've talked.
So I don't have any updates as well. Mayor, can I just ask that when
you go and the vote is taken on Thursday at MAG, would you just
let us know when that's— I'm sure you will, but if you just send us
a text or something, it'd be nice to know that that passed and now that
funding will become available for us. My hopes is, as you know,
you've advocated for us too, is to move some of the other projects
up. But so far it's my— my— I wish you well. Yeah, I thought I
was going to get it done, and I'm less optimistic as I used to be,
I'll say that. But we're still pushing, man. We're leaning on them to get
that northern connection as well. So I don't know, David has to— and part
of that was what you mentioned earlier, the, um, reprioritizing some
of that funding and the contingencies. So I'll let you know the update. You'll be
the first to know. Um, with that, I know we do have a few
things to go back into In the meantime, we have
to come back out here to adjourn later, right? So we'll,
we'll entertain a motion. Mayor,
I move that the Eagle Mountain City Council move into
a closed session pursuant to Section 52-4-205
of the Utah Code Annotated. Second. Okay, we have a motion by
Councilmember Wood and a second by Councilmember Whiting. Councilmember Clark?
Yes. Councilmember Wright? Yes. Councilmember Whiting? Yes. Councilmember Wood? Yes.
Councilmember Herish? Yes. Thank you.
Are you recording yet? Yes? It is 9:41
PM. We're back into our regular session, and there's a
few more things that I'm sure everybody wants to go over. And the first one
is— Motion to adjourn. Second. Motion to adjourn by Councilmember
Wood, a second by Councilmember Wright. All in favor? Aye. Unanimous.
We are adjourned at 9:41.